All right, Sam, ready to get back into
it?
By the power of the Lord Jesus Christ.
So, may the Lord anoint you and I. May
the Lord Jesus correct all errors in us,
bad theology, destroy all sin in us. May
the Lord have mercy on us, forgive us,
and steal us by his spirit. May the
spirit teach through us and give us
perfect recall and ex Jesus of the
scriptures to take all these people
captive so they turn to the true Jesus
Christ. May the Lord bless your
ministry, prosper you, and preserve you
for the glory of the father, son spirit
in Jesus name. We're ready, brother.
Ready.
Let's go.
Now, when Jesus died,
who raised Jesus from the grave? Let's
look at that. Let's look at first Peter
chapter 3 verse 18.
It says, "For which also also hath once
suffered for sins, the just for the
unjust, the mighty um bring us to God,
the that he might bring us to God, being
put to death in the flesh, but quickened
by the spirit." We understand that there
is a trinity.
We understand that there's a Godhead.
And so now although Jesus was dead and
and although Jesus was fully dead, we
understand that the Holy Ghost is still
functioning. The Holy Ghost is still
conscious. The Holy Ghost is still aware
and he's still working. Correct? Now
let's go to Galatians chapter 1 verse
one.
It says Paul an apostle not of men
neither by man but by Jesus Christ and
God the father who raised him from the
dead. So according to this verse who
raised Jesus from the dead? God the
father.
Mhm.
So we understand that although Jesus was
fully dead the father is still alive.
The father is still functioning. The
father is still conscious. And so he's
able to run the universe now.
All right. So Sam, before we hear you
respond, for those that may not have
seen part one, um they are responding to
an older video of Sam's regarding the
nature of man and the state of the dead.
But apparently for those that did see
part one, these gentlemen do not recall
what they looked at a mere five minutes
prior to this where they read John 10
and Jesus saying that he would raise
himself, which isn't a one-off, by the
way. John 2 says the same thing. We
looked at both of those as well in part
one. But now they point to first Peter
3:19 and Galatians 1, which is supposed
to prove that Jesus wasn't running the
universe while his physical body lay in
the grave because the Holy Spirit and
the father were still aware and
conscious. Now, like I said, Sam, before
we hear your response, notice what their
prophetist comments on this in Desire of
Ages, a book she claimed the SDA church
upholds and is barricaded apparently by
a thus saith the Lord.
First, we're going to look at the Desire
of Ages quote that they are essentially
reiterating. But first, their
fundamental beliefs book. This is an
exposition by the SDA church of their 28
fundamental beliefs.
Quote, "Jesus asserted his omnipresence
with the asurances, lo, I with you
always, even to the end of the age."
Matthew 28:20. And where two or three
are gathered together in my name, I am
there in the midst of them. Matthew
18:20. Although his divinity has the
natural ability of omnipresence.
The incarnate Christ has voluntarily
limited himself in this respect.
He has chosen to be omnipresent through
the ministry of the Holy Spirit. John
14:16-18
close quote. So the aven Jesus is not
truly omnipresent. By taking on the
nature of humanity, he limited himself
in this capacity. And this is
ultimately, like I said, coming from
Ellen White and the Desire of Ages.
Notice quote, the Holy Spirit is
Christ's representative, but divested of
the personality of humanity and
independent thereof.
Cumbered with humanity, Christ could not
be in every place personally. Therefore,
it was for their interest that he should
go to the father and send the spirit to
be his successor on earth. No one could
then have any advantage because of his
location or his personal contact with
Christ. By this, the spirit of the
savior would be accessible to all. In
this sense, he would be nearer to them
than if he had not ascended on high.
Close quote. So, this is essentially
what they are getting at. With this in
mind, what is your response to Deonte,
the gentleman that said these things
that Jesus wasn't running the universe
while his physical body was dead? It was
only the father and the holy spirit.
Yeah. Blasphemy obviously, but I just
want clarification from Ellen G. White's
position.
As you're reading this, I'm trying to
understand it. You would obviously
understand her. This is your forte and
God bless you for exposing this. So
she's saying the Holy Spirit is Christ's
representative by divested a person of
humanity.
Now I don't understand what she means
here. She's saying the Holy Spirit is
Christ's presence
and not a divine person or that the Holy
Spirit did not become human because this
max of almost like Ntorianism because
from the way I'm reading it, she has a
human person who is Jesus which means
he's a divine person and human person.
The reason why I say that for people
because historically
anyone who taught that Christ became a
human person or was two persons divine
human was was condemned as a heretic.
Jesus is one eternal uncreated divine
person dukan a human nature a physical
body human mind human emotions and will
but he not become a human person. So
what is she saying here? I don't
understand.
And this is why you have to know the
SDA, excuse me, dictionary. And so we've
looked at this before on the channel.
And so she's actually contradicted
herself here with some other statements
that she's made. But this book is little
preface for you. This book is supposed
to be when they finally got all of their
Christology ironed out. 1898.
That's when this book was was published.
And by that point is when their version
of the trinity, their heavenly trio was
supposed to be well essentially
trinitarian because they believe in
three divine persons. That's what they
like to say. They don't like to talk
about the oneness and being of God. So
when they use the word person, they're
referring to a tangible literal form.
And we looked at this uh it's been over
a year. I don't expect you to remember
this, but we looked at this on your
platform um when we went through a
number of their quotes and I was
explaining to you what they mean by
terms. What they mean by terms is that's
what personality is. It is having a
literal tangible form. And then Ellen
White was shown a vision allegedly to
confirm this this leg uh this it's in
multiple places but um it's in early
writings but she claims to be shown a
vision after they were contemplating
this and it was over what the creed says
um and a lot of Protestant confessions
um say regarding God being without body
and parts. And so Ellen received a
vision where she talked to Jesus and she
asked him, "Does your father have a form
like you do?" And he said, "Yes, but you
couldn't behold it or you would cease to
exist." And you had pointed out. So she
lowers Jesus to you. She could see
Jesus, but she couldn't see the father.
Um, and so but but here she contradicts
what she says actually uh one or two
years prior. I can't remember the date
on that exactly, but it's right prior to
this where she said that the Holy Spirit
is as much a person as the father and
the son are persons, but he's invisible
to the human eye. and she said he was
walking around Aendale College in the
19th century. Um, but he was invisible.
Um, but then she'll go on to say stuff
like this where she says, "Well, the
Holy Spirit is Christ's representative.
He is a person, but he's Christ's
representative in Christ's physical
human absence."
So, they're not saying the same thing as
like Jehovah's Witnesses would say at
this point in the theology. Y
earlier on in the timeline, you would
have had the pioneers who were saying
things like the Holy Spirit is just like
the father and the son's um like divine
presence or energy apart from them
physically being there. So she has some
vestigages and remnants of that that are
still making themselves seen here. But
they're going to tell you, well, the
Holy Spirit is a person.
Okay. So they want to affirm the
personhood of the Holy Spirit. Yeah.
There's too much unpacked, too much
confusion, too much error, too much
blasphemy. But glory to God. One thing
guys, I wanted you to know, I am blocked
from YouTube for two weeks because
Muslims complain about me exposing some
terrorism taking place. And so YouTube
being blocked me for two weeks. And I
won't be able to stream for two weeks
because I would like to have aired this
on YouTube. So I'm doing it on Rumble to
get in more traffic. So keep that in
mind. Pray God will preserve the
channel. The Lord give me a favor
because if I get a third strike, it's
gone. So, just let you know, I'm not on
YouTube because I want more people
subscribe. So, you guys on Rumble
Facebook, come here, subscribe, help
this brother grow for the glory of
Christ because it's needed. Now, coming
back to the issue, it is vitally
important to everyone rewatch
part one. And those who haven't watch
part one, but we're going to look at the
passages again. Notice the clear
blasphemy. They're denying Christ is
truly God on earth. And they're denying
that Christ was consciously alive. Read
between the lines. The father was alive.
The spirit is alive. So the father
sustaining creation. The spirit raised
Jesus because Jesus was fully dead.
In other words, Jesus ceased to be
conscious, which is impossible if he's a
divine person. Because if he's an
eternal divine person, being God
means by his very nature, he cannot
cease to exist. He cannot cease to be
conscious. So here we have them now on
record. Now I don't know if the
Adventist scholars will recognize them
as being bonafide legitimate apologists.
They'll say, "Well, yeah, these guys
don't represent us." I hope they would
disown them because this is blasphemy. I
want you to hear this. They just admit
to you that Jesus wasn't truly God and
he ceased to exist for those three days,
but the father was still alive. Spirit
is still alive. Spirit raised Jesus and
the father is sustaining creation
because Jesus was fully dead. I.e. he no
longer consciously existed. So they
don't believe that Jesus is truly God in
the flesh. This is heresy. This is
blasphemy. So I'm glad you guys expose
yourselves. That's number one. Number
two, the same Bible says the father
raised Jesus, Jesus raised himself, and
the spirit raised Jesus. Same Bible says
the father raised the dead at the last
day. Jesus will raise the dead at the
last day and the spirit will raise the
dead at the last day. Because if we
don't do Bible ping pong and we do what
one Christian reformed scholar
said to a Muslim, eeny, meeny, miny, mo,
I'll take this verse, but the rest got
to go. But we try to breathe the Bible
in context, right? Because they I don't
know if they affirm it because they're
not even Protestants because they
condemn Protestants and Catholics
together. But for those who fle believe
solos scriptor to scriptor the tora part
tora scriptures in their totality
because believe these books are all
inspired by the same spirit and they
complement one another they do not
contradict. So if you do tota scriptorra
father raised Jesus son raised himself
spirit raised Jesus because as the one
god they do all things inseparably they
may assume different roles but they're
performing the same actions. Now we
don't believe the father became flesh or
the spirit became flesh. Jesus became
flesh. But even in the flesh Jesus
claims the father is with him in him
working through him doing the miracles
with Jesus and the spirit. All three of
them were working through the human body
of Christ doing the same works together.
So it's not that the father raised Jesus
full stop or Jesus raised himself full
stop or the spirit raised Jesus full
stop. It's all of the above. So, let's
look at that just to refresh people's
memories. Now, you mentioned John
2:19-22. Let's look at that one more
time.
Yep.
One more time.
So, I don't understand.
H. Anyway, I
Well, and Sam, see, this also gives you
insight into how See, they're going to
tell you, "We believe Jesus," and you're
going to hear this, it's when we get to
further into the video, they're going to
insist, "No, we we're not saying Jesus
isn't God. It's just a constant mishmash
of cognitive dissonance and confusion
and not being able to track with what
you're saying and what these terms
actually mean. They don't even mean the
same thing when they use the word God.
They mean something entirely different.
It's like a familial term. It's almost
like your last name.
Yeah.
You like but but there's really actually
in in Orthodox Adventist
Christologology, meaning Ellen White,
there's a hierarchy. You almost have
like a monarchianism that's mixed in
there as well where the father is the
almighty and the son is eternally
subordinate um or a lesser etc.
And you prove that John
right you prove that in my sessions
where Jesus was made almighty equal to
the father.
Correct. Correct. We've looked at that
at this point probably a hundred times
on this platform.
But now we're going to reacquaint you
with pastor but I'm going to add some
more. And then first Peter 3 ironically
destroys soul sleep. Isn't that ironic?
Yeah. I know. I'm just like, what?
Yeah. It's ironic because 1 Peter 3:18,
had he read it all the way to 22, he
would have said that when Christ was
dead in the flesh, he went to the
spirits who are in prison, right? He
went and proclaimed to the spirits in
prison who long ago disobeyed in days of
Noah. But according to them, there are
no spirits in no prison because these
spirits are consciously in prison in
dungeons of darkness.
But we'll get to that.
They don't bring up the harrowing of
hell. um obviously because it causes
serious problems but they have I I wish
they would have so we could have gotten
into you hearing uh their arguments but
nevertheless
John 2:19-22
Jesus answered them destroy this temple
and in 3 days I will raise it up the
Jews then said it has taken 46 years to
build this temple and you will raise it
up in three days but he was speaking
about the temple of his body when
therefore he was raised from the dead
his disciples remembered that he had
said this and they believed the
scripture and the word that Jesus had
spoken. Now they believe in well I don't
know if they do anyway they claim to
believe in the totality of scriptures
and you need to because the Bible's
inspired inherent historically accurate
word of God here Jesus says I myself
personally will raise my own temple
meaning my body in three days and we
know that from John 10:17 but I'm going
to give you some other nuggets
where people may not be aware here you
see the harmonious consistency
miraculous structure of the Bible.
Meaning you have different books written
by different authors in different
periods. But because the author is one,
you will find that certain books
presuppose
statements found in other writings. For
example, John is the only one that has
Jesus saying, "Destroy this temple. You
destroy this temple and I will raise it
up in three days." But both Mark and
Matthew presuppose this tradition
because at Jesus's trial, one of the
accusations raised against him is the
following in Mark 14 57 to 58. So let's
work through this systematically and
slowly. Mark 14, I'm going to show you.
Father, son, Holy Spirit raised Jesus.
Father, Holy Spirit raised the dead at
the last day. And Father, Holy Spirit
were doing the miracles on earth
together. It's not either or. It's
above. It's all of the above.
Yep. Mark 14:57-58. What does it say?
Oh, 57. Sorry.
Watch your
And some stood up and bore false witness
against him, saying, "We heard him say,
I will destroy this temple that is made
with hands, and in three days I will
build another not made with hands." Yet
even about this, their testimony did not
agree.
I meant to say Mark 14 575. I did say
that, right? because you at 58 to 59.
Oh, you did 57 59.
Yeah. Yeah.
My apologies. Went to 59. Got this. Now,
notice,
let me explain what a false witness
doesn't mean. False witness doesn't mean
someone's just going to lie on the spot.
That's part of it. A false witness is a
malicious witness who will take your
words and twist them. So, it's not that
a false witness in the Bible is someone
who just makes up lies. That's part of
it, but it's more than that. It's
someone who takes your words, twists
them in order to present you in a very
negative light. So notice the
accusation. They heard him say, "I will
destroy this temple that is made with
hands, and in three days I will build
another not made with hands." Now,
you'll never find in John 21:19:22 Jesus
saying what they accuse him of. That
doesn't mean they're making it up. They
confused two sayings of Jesus
and they did it deliberately because
John does affirm Jesus said destroy this
temple not I will destroy it. You
destroy this temple I raise up in three
days. He's talking about the body. You
will destroy my temple the body and I'll
raise it up in three days. But it is
true that Jesus did say because the Jews
would reject him. He would then bring
judgment upon Jerusalem temple and have
Jerusalem and temple destroyed. Yeah,
that's found in Mark 13. That's found in
Matthew 24, Luke 21, Luke 19:41-44. So
he did say he would destroy the temple
and Jerusalem because of their
rejection. And he did say he would raise
up the temple three days, but he was
talking about two different things. But
here again, they heard what Jesus said.
Yeah.
Butchered what he said, confused what he
said in order to find him guilty of
blasphemy. Why? Because the most
sacrilegious thing you could say is to
say you as a Jew would destroy the
temple because God lived in it. So
they're finding a re reason to have him
killed. So notice Mark is is
presupposing a tradition where Jesus
went around saying destroy the temple.
I'll raise it up three days his body.
And he also said that this temple will
be destroyed because of the rejection of
Jesus. Jesus said both. Now, it's John
who tells us what Jesus actually said.
It wasn't the temple in Jerusalem that
the Jews misunderstood. Remember, they
misunderstood him.
Yeah.
It's taken 46 years to build this
temple. You will raise it up three days.
So right there John is giving you the
background
where here we find the eyewitnesses are
discombobulated
misconstruing misinterping Jesus' words
but Mark doesn't tell you when or where
Jesus said it. John fills out the
details and Jesus said it at the
beginning of his ministry after he
turned water into wine when he went to
Jerusalem during the feast of Passover.
So Jesus did say it, but not the way
they assumed it because they're
misunderstanding or deliberately
perverting his words. So here's another
passage, you Adventists, where Jesus
himself says, "I will raise up the
temple of my body in three days." That
was Mark 14:578. And when he's on the
cross, look how they mock him. Mark
15:29.
Mark 15:29.
And those who passed by derided him,
wagging their heads and saying, "Aha,
you who would destroy the temple and
rebuild it in three days."
So he did say, "Destroy the temple, I'll
raise up in three days." But he wasn't
saying, "I'm going to destroy my
temple." That's where they got confused.
Even in John 21:19 and 22, you see the
confusion. It has taken 46 years to
build the temple. You'll raise it up
three days. So there you go. Mark also
presupposes this tradition of Jesus
which John records. But just like they
misunderstood Jesus in John 2 here
they're not a misunderstanding but it
seems they're deliberately twisting his
words to find grounds to condemn him for
blasphemy therefore worthy of death. So
Christ raised himself. Father raised
Jesus. Spirit raised Jes. Now they
showed you where the father raised Jesus
and the spirit raised Jesus. Now we have
Jesus raising Jesus. Now what about
resurrecting the dead at the last day
because I want to show you if you are
total scriptura solos scripter and you
let scripture interpret scripture the
Bible is clear father holy spirit
together as the one god raise Jesus's
body father son spirit together as the
one god are the source of life father
son spirit together as the one god will
raise the dead at the last day it's not
either or so let's go to John 6 and
we're going to read
John 6 39-44.
So watch here.
And this is the will of him who sent me
that I should lose nothing of all that
he has given me, but raise it up on the
last day.
For this is the will of my father, that
everyone who looks on the Son and
believes in him should have eternal
life, and I will raise him up on the
last day. So the Jews grumbled about him
because he said, "I am the bread that
came down from heaven." They said, "Is
not this Jesus the son of Joseph whose
father and mother we know? How does he
now say I've come down from heaven?"
Jesus answered them, "Do not grumble
among yourselves. No one can come to me
unless the father who sent me draws him,
and I will raise him up on the last
day."
Okay. So now Jesus raises the dead on
the last day. Okay. Now, let's go to
John 5. We're going to read 21:29.
John 5 21:29. Now, guys, be patient with
us because as we're refuting their
heresy, we're providing the overwhelming
evidence for the Trinity and their
perfect operations.
There's a technical term for this. It's
called
Yeah. In separate operations, peris.
Now, watch here. John 5:21. Just read
21.
For as the father raises the dead and
gives them life, so also the son gives
life to whom he will.
Now remember this, father gives life,
son gives life. And I'm going to show
you where it says holy spirit gives
life. Father gives life. Son gives life.
And you're going to see where it says
the spirit gives life. And it is not a
coincidence. It's three and only three.
Only these three and these three alone
are set to do the things that only God
can do. There's no fourth. You won't
find a fourth figure. So here, father
gives life. I give life. Now, who will
raise the dead physically from the tombs
and spiritually as well? John 5:25, what
does it say?
Truly, truly, I say to you, an hour is
coming and is now here when the dead
will hear the voice of the son of God,
and those who hear will live.
So, the voice of the son of God, right?
Yep.
Now, 28:29,
whose voice will the dead hear at the
last day and be raised physically from
the tombs? Watch here. Do not marvel at
this, for an hour is coming when all who
are in the tombs will hear his voice and
come out. Those who have done good to
the resurrection of life, and those who
have done evil to the resurrection of
judgment. So the voice of the son of God
raises people spiritually and
physically. All right? Son gives life,
father gives life. Go to John 663. Watch
the pattern here. This is why we're
trinitarians because the Bible is a
trinitarian book and you find these
trinitarian patterns all over. So then
John 663. Who else gives life? We were
told the father gives life, the son
gives life. Who else gives life?
It is the spirit who gives life. The
flesh is no help at all. The words that
I've spoken to you are spirit and life.
So now the spirit gives life. It's only
these three and these three alone.
That's why we're trinitarian. The spirit
gives life. All right. Remember Jesus
raises them at the last day, raises the
dead physically and glorifies believers
and punishes the wicked. Jesus gives
life. Father gives life. Spirit gives
life. But who else raises the dead at
the last day? Well, now let's go to
Romans 8 and read verses 9 to13.
Now watch here.
Romans 893. Watch the trinitarian
pattern. So guys, we're going to kill
several birds, one stone. You'll see the
massive overwhelming evidence for the
Trinity and these blasphemies that are
being refuted because obviously they're
not true trinitarians. They're not. They
may believe in a form of the trinity but
it's not the biblical trinity and I'm
not appealing to creeds solos scriptor
to scriptoral.
Yeah because and this is needs to be
said as well Sam that you know we
mentioned inseparable operations you
mentioned uh if I if we want to do the
real irraspian paracaresis
yes
um people may say you know that where
are those terms coming from that's not a
term in the bible etc. And the point is
is what you're showing these are just
terms that are used to not be verbose
every time. Like we're being tedious
here because we have to be unfortunately
this is what it's required. Everything's
not in just little sound bites and specs
etc. Sometimes you have to be tedious
like this. Well, you can't do that all
the time. So we use terms to summarize
and it tells you if you understand what
paracaresis is or the paracoritic
relationship um you go oh okay. And so
it keeps people from having to be
long-winded. That's essentially what's
going on. But it's completely biblical
as you're seeing.
Yep. In Romans 8:9-13, now watch. Who
will give life to our mortal bodies when
they're dead? We were told Jesus does
that. He raises the dead out of their
tombs. But here, notice who it is.
Romans 8 9-13. Watch here.
You, however, are not in the flesh, but
in the spirit. If, in fact, the spirit
of God dwells in you. Anyone who does
not have the spirit of Christ does not
belong to him. But if Christ is in you,
although the body is dead because of
sin, the spirit is life because of
righteousness. If the spirit of him who
raised Jesus from the dead dwells in
you, he who raised Christ Jesus from the
dead will also give life to your mortal
bodies through his spirit who dwells in
you.
H So who will make our bodies immortal?
The spirit of God who's in us, right?
Yep.
And notice the spirit of God is a spirit
of Christ and it is Christ. meaning not
that Christ is the holy spirit but the
holy spirit belongs to the father and
son and if the spirit is in you he then
connects you to the father and son so
that all of them are in you
that's the teaching of scripture the
teaching of scripture is the spirit
connects me to the father and son and
the spirit makes me one with the father
and son so that's the father son spirit
dwelling with me and in me and working
through me it's not just the spirit it's
father son and spirit in respect to the
divine nature so now it's the spirit who
gives life to our mortal bodies, meaning
raises the dead physically because he
already made us alive inwardly. All
right. Now, go to 1 Corinthians 6:14.
Who will raise the dead at the last day?
1 Corinthians 6:14.
And God raised the Lord and will also
raise us up by his power.
H So wait, God raised the Lord Jesus
physically, right?
Correct. That means when we die, he will
also raise us physically by his power.
But guys, John 5 258 29 John 6 39-4 John
6:44 John 6:54 which you did not read
Jesus I will raise the dead physically
both the wicked and righteous from their
tombs and I will make believers
immortal. Here it's God the Father will
raise the dead in Christ and make them
immortal. And then the father gives
life, son gives life, but the spirit
gives life. And the spirit will raise
our bodies and make them immortal.
H go to 2 Corinthians 4:14. Everyone
seeing the trinitarian pattern here?
2 Corinthians 4:14.
Knowing that he who raised the Lord
Jesus will raise us also with Jesus and
bring us with you into his presence.
Oh, so the father. Huh?
Yep.
But in 2 Corinthians 3:6, who gives
life?
The spirit.
Yep. Show it to them, brother. So, see,
get it now. He'll tell you. I don't even
know what clips he's playing. I don't
know. I don't watch these guys. I really
don't.
Second Corinthians 3:6,
right?
2 Corinthians 3:6.
Yep.
Who has made us sufficient to be
ministers of a new covenant? Not of the
letter, but of the spirit.
For the letter kills, but the spirit
gives life.
The trinity. Father gives life. Son
gives life. Spirit gives life. Father
raises the dead at the last day. Son
raises the dead last day. So does the
Holy Spirit. Final one, 1 Timothy 6:13.
And as you go to 1 Timothy 6:13, I want
to ask you a question. What Bible
version do they stick with?
Um, typ it depends. But if you're going
to get some that are sticklers, it's
going to be the King James.
Okay. But they will not deviate from
translations that follow, let's say, the
received text, Texas receptus majority
text, right? Because I've seen Doug
Batcher use the New King James.
Yeah. Right. So that's I'm saying some
some are like you'll find like a small
strain of King James only, but that's
not like an official position of the
organization. You'll get all sorts of
translations.
Yeah. I I asked that because if they go
with the King James, New King James, now
they have a bigger problem. There is a
reading in John 3:13 that's supported by
early Greek manuscripts and the majority
of later Greek manuscripts and ancient
versions that will really cause a
nightmare to them. And I'll explain why
in a minute. But this is the majority of
the Greek manuscripts of John 3:13. The
majority of them and many early copies
and ancient versions and even some of
the early church writers mention this
line that some of the early Greek
papyrite do not have and it's a
nightmare and I'll show you what I mean
in a minute. Now 1 Timothy 6:13
I charge you in the presence of God who
gives life to all things and of Christ
Jesus who is his testimony before
Pontius Pilate made the good confession.
Who gives life to all things?
God the Father.
But I was told the Son gives life and he
gives it to whom he wants and the spirit
gives life. So you're seeing a
trinitarian pattern here.
Of course.
Notice guys, it's only three and these
three alone. There is no fourth because
that's the one true God. The Bible
forced the church to articulate the
doctrine of the Trinity. Now watch this
reading. It's in the King James, New
King James. It's in the majority of
Greek copies, what's called the
Byzantine text, the majority text. and
it's found in many early witnesses,
Greek witnesses and early writers. This
is the best attested reading and
therefore is original. But they're going
to now do Bible hopscotch and they'll go
with versions that prioritize earlier
Greek papyr say, "Well, no, look at John
3:13, either New King James or even the
King James."
Okay.
Watch here.
And no man hath ascended up to heaven,
but he that came down from heaven, even
the son of man, which is in heaven.
You got right there, annihilation. Jesus
physically on earth, physically limited
to time and space, but because he's God,
he's in heaven and earth at the same
time.
And this reading is the best to test the
reading. It's not just because I like
it. The majority of Greek copies, the
majority texts have it. Many early
copies have it. Early Christian writers
when they quote it have this reading. It
is the best attested reading and
therefore original. So if you go with
King James, they're quoting King James.
Now watch. I'm more of a prophet than LG
White. I prophesy they're gonna abandon
the King James New King James reading of
this verse because that means Jesus is
still omnipresent God physically on
earth but he is God who is in heaven and
earth because he sustains all creation
while he was on earth just like
physically in heaven but he's still
present with us by virtue of being God
not just by because of the spirit yes
it's the spirit that connects us to the
father and son because where the spirit
is the father and son are
yeah Now the final element to my
argument of what we call inseparable
operations. Who is doing the miracles on
earth? All of the above. Father, son,
and spirit.
Because in certain places Jesus says
he's doing the works in imitation of the
father. Other places say the father
doing the works. And then he says the
spirit. For example, one more time. John
5:19-21.
Sam, I can't tell you how many former
Adventists I've talked to that once this
clicked because of the way they were
taught the God that they were taught
about in Adventism seemed like divided.
They they'd read one place and they'd
say, "But this says the father did it,
but this says the spirit did it." And so
because of what they teach about person
and being and that and trying to dismiss
these is like well that's Greek and
Aristoilian thinking and this sort of
stuff not understanding that well when
you actually do that you just create a
mess of confusion. Um once this clicks
for them their mind is like blown
because you're right it's a both hand.
It's not an eitheror. There's not
division going on here. Jesus did not,
cuz for those that may have missed the
beginning, he he essentially told us
that while Jesus was dead, and we're
going to hear more of this later, by the
way, this isn't just a one-off in the
the discussion.
Um, while Jesus was dead, remember, they
never they never proved in part one what
the Adventist Church teaches about death
is what death means according to the
Bible. They just assumed it and then
they went on to say Jesus really died.
We really believe he was dead. Meaning,
he was just like we are. And when we
die, we essentially cease to exist. And
the defense given for who was running
the universe is well, the father and the
spirit were able to to cover it while
the son was dead. And right there, no,
that that's that is not correct at all.
And notice, bear witness, I've only used
scripture.
Correct?
I didn't go to the creeds or to
philosophy. I just use scripture because
it was the scriptures that forced me to
my positions. Now, I may get some things
wrong, misunderstand, but it's
scriptural teaching that drives me to
embrace something. I hope I'm being
sincere to that. And may the Lord
correct me if I'm mistaken or deceived.
Now, watch here who's doing the works.
Father and son together. John 5:1 19-21.
So Jesus said to them, "Truly, truly, I
say to you, the Son can do nothing of
his own accord, but only what he sees
the Father doing. For whatever the
Father does, that the Son does likewise.
For the Father loves the Son and shows
him all that he himself is doing. And
greater works than these will he show
him, so that you may marvel. For as the
Father raises the dead and gives them
life, so also the Son gives life to whom
he will. Pay attention to what the Lord
did not say. He didn't say, "It's the
father doing it. I'm a passive agent."
No. Father and I together are actively
doing the same works and I do whatever
he does the way he does it. So, it's the
father and the son together actively
doing the same works. Can't get around
this. It's not Jesus's passive. The
father is doing it. I and the father do
the works because what he does I do in
imitation of him. Okay. Now, open up
John 10 and read from 25 39. We have to
do this to teach them the trinity.
Hopefully, they will learn 25 and
correct their bad theology. Read 25 to
30 for me.
Okay.
Jesus answered them. I told you and you
do not believe. The works that I do in
my father's name bear witness about me.
He does it right. The works I do by the
authority because my father's authorized
me. I'm doing these works. But it's not
just him. Watch what happens.
But do you not believe because you are
among my sheep? My sheep hear my voice
and I know them and they follow me. I
give them eternal life
and they will never perish and no one
will snatch them out of my hand.
The father who has given them to me is
greater than all and no one is able to
snatch them out of the father's hand.
Now you catch it there. I'm the one who
will give them eternal life. I'm the one
who preserve them in my hand my power.
No one can pluck them. They never
perish. Likewise, they're in my father's
hand, and no one can pluck down one of
my father's hand. Because it's I and the
father together preserving the sheep.
That's why he says, "I and the father
are one." Now read 31-33.
The Jews picked up stones again to stone
him. Jesus answered them, "I've shown
you many good works from the father. For
which of them are you going to stone
me?"
I showed you many I've been doing good
works. Meaning, I'm doing what the
father does. So when I see the father
act, I act inseparably with him. He's
doing them with me. I'm doing them with
him. So go ahead.
I have shown you many good works from
the father. For which of them are you
going to stone me? The Jews answered
him, it is not for a good work that we
are going to stone you, but for
blasphemy because you being a man, make
yourself God.
Now you can skip 34 to 36. Read 37 38.
Who's doing the miracles?
If I am not doing the works of my
father, then do not believe me. But if I
do them, even though you do not believe
me, believe the works, that you may know
and understand that the Father is in me
and I am in the Father. Again, they
sought to arrest him, but he escaped
from their hands. Can he be any clearer?
It's not just the Father. Father and I
are doing the works. I'm doing the works
from the Father because when he acts, I
act inseparably with him. That's clear
as day, right?
Yep.
But now go to John 14 and you're going
to read verse 7 all the way to to 11.
You don't need 3:12. Now watch here
and then we can go to the next point.
Sorry guys, it takes them few minutes to
make an error and it takes us longer to
demolish that error.
If you had known me, you would have
known my father also. From now on, you
do know him and have seen him. Philip
said to him,"Lord, show us the father
and is it enough for us?" Jesus said to
them or said to him, "Have I been with
you so long and you still do not know
me, Philillip? Whoever has seen me has
seen the father?" How can you say, "Show
us the father? Do you not believe that I
am in the father and the father is in
me?" The words that I say to you, I do
not speak on my own authority. But the
Father who dwells in me does his works.
Believe me that I am in the Father and
the Father is in me. Or else believe on
account of the works themselves.
But in 10 it says the Father is doing
the works. Right.
Correct.
Now where's the Holy Spirit in all this?
Well, go to Matthew 12:28.
So the father is doing the miracles
through Jesus. When Jesus on earth
physically, Jesus is doing the miracles
and the spirit is trinity.
But if it is by the spirit of God that I
cast out demons, then the kingdom of God
has come upon you. Yeah. Luke Luke uh 13
as well.
Did you catch it? So Jesus does the
miracles of casting out demons by the
spirit of God.
Correct.
But then he does the miracles and the
father, see, trinity, it's all of the
above. So what they're doing is they're
pitting scripture against scripture. If
one place says it says the father raises
Jesus that means Jesus didn't raise
himself. Or if the spirit raised Jesus
that means Jesus raised himself. So why
don't we reason? Well if the spirit
raised Jesus then the father did. Or if
the father raised Jesus spirit. See this
is what you do. If you're not biblically
illiterate and untrained and you're
seeking to impose on the Bible a
tradition from an outside source. You're
going to pervert scripture and create
contradictions when none exists. So
you're wrong. Jesus was still alive. He
was still omnipresent. We demonstrated
last week the passages that while
physically on earth, he's still
omnipresent by virtue of being God,
overseeing all things. So that's guys
got to repent. So that's out the box.
Now, do you want me to show how first
Peter 3 destroys soul sleep? I mean, you
know it, but I don't know if others do.
Yeah, of course. But before we do that,
one bonus point on this, Sam. The
parallel of this. In Luke 13, it doesn't
say by the spirit of God I cast out
demons. Jesus says, "If I do it by the
finger of God."
Yep.
So, there's just another consistent. How
do you square both of those away? You'll
get um you know, pagans that are going
to say, "Well, that looks like a a
contradiction. One place it says the
spirit, one place it says the finger of
God." And if you can't explain to that
person, well, right, because the Bible
teaches the Trinity,
that's perfectly consistent with
Trinitarian theology.
So, understand what he's saying because
in Luke 11:20 says, "By the finger of
God,"
or Luke 11, sorry, I could say 13.
Matthew 12:28, "By the spirit of God."
And then Acts 2:22, Peter tells us that
Jesus was a man accredited by God
by whom God did signs and wonders. So
there's God the Father. In Acts 10:38,
God anointed with the Spirit and with
power to go about doing good things and
deliver those who oppressed by Satan.
See, if you don't know how to interpret
scripture, you're going to create
contradictions galore. Anyway, I hope
that settles it. Now watch the passage
they cited shows you there are people
who are alive individuals who are alive
without their physical bodies who are
destroyed in the flood but they're alive
and in prison and conscious and Jesus
went to them and proclaimed to them and
this is how the early Christians
interpret this passage and that's how
they're interpreting it because they
cited it that way that he was put to
death in flesh made alive by the spirit
but where was he during those days that
his body was in the tomb. 1 Peter
3:18-22.
For Christ also suffered once for sins,
the righteous for the unrighteous, that
he might bring us to God, being put to
death in the flesh, but made alive in
the spirit, in which he went and
proclaimed to the spirits in prison,
because they formally did not obey when
God's patience waited in the days of
Noah while the ark was being prepared in
which a few that is eight persons were
brought safely through water. baptism
which corresponds to this now saves you
not as a removal of dirt from the body
but as an appeal to God for a good
conscience through the resurrection of
Jesus Christ who has gone into heaven
and is at the right hand of God with
angels authorities and powers having
been subjected to him. Now, let me
guess. Are they going to explain away
these spirits in prison? And what is
prison to them? Because here it says,
"These are spirits who are now in prison
who disobeyed at the time of Noah and
were destroyed by the flood." Notice
they don't have bodies. Their spirits in
prison because their bodies were
destroyed.
Correct.
What do they I'm curious because you
know more than me. What do they say
about spirits in prison? Not their body
because their body was destroyed in the
flood, but they're still there as
spirits.
Uh who do you mean? What do you mean by
they? because I'm not about these guys
or even Adventism generals.
Yeah. So I again I would need to look at
to give you an answer on officially I
would need to reference their Bible
commentary which I haven't done on this
uh specific pricky but I've heard all
sorts of answers from individual
Adventists. So there's a wide board of
of things I've heard but again those are
not going to be the representatives of
the organization necessarily.
Guys understand what it's saying. Christ
who was put to death in the flesh but
was still alive went to proclaim to not
human beings with physical bodies
spirits their bodies were destroyed in
the time of Noah they're in prison now
this was the view of the early
Christians later on people adopted a
second view but just to make it a little
harder for them that these spirits are
consciously in prison after their bodies
destroyed in the flood let's see what
Peter says about angels who disobeyed.
Where are they? Second Peter 2:4.
Because I still would I don't know. Do
they believe I don't know what they
believe about angels. So, do they
believe angels also will be wiped out of
existence or what? I don't know.
Yeah. Yeah. Um so, at the end of the
great controversy, um when Ellen talks
about the annihilation that's going to
happen. Um they believe in a threefold
phase of judgment. And so the
investigative judgment, then the
millennial reign judgment, and then the
postmillennial judgment, which is the
execution of and where they'll
essentially be annihilated. That means
the wicked along with Satan and his
angels.
Okay? So they believe eventually angelic
creatures will be wiped out. But we have
a problem here, folks, because second
Peter 2:4, Peter is assume presuppos I
believe. Now I know people may disagree
with me, but then June solidifies it.
Jude, why? Now, let me give you a little
This is important for you guys who want
to interpret scriptures reverently.
If you read Second Peter 2 and Jude,
they're virtually identical. Just read
it, guys. Tonight, read second Peter 2
and Jude, you're going to see that they
are so similar and in many aspects the
same because they're talking about the
same theme and bring up similar examples
to show that God is consistent in
destroying false teachers and prophets.
Now, I mentioned that because Jude also
references Enoch. Jude, and ironically,
Jude is one of their get-go books to
show that Michael must be Jesus, which
now going to backfire. In Jude, he's
going to mention these angels that Peter
mentions. But before I further expound
on it, let's first look at second Peter
2:4.
For if God did not spare angels when
they sinned, but cast them into hell,
and committed them to chains of gloomy
darkness to be kept until the judgment,
what what are you keeping in chains
until the day of judgment if they're no
longer consciously alive? And by the
way, the word hell is the Greek word is
tartar
and it's tarterus.
It's actually the Greek word. It's
tarterus. Now you got problems folks
because Peter is writing to Gentiles
who've converted to the faith and he's
using a term that to them would have
meant a realm in which they're actually
conscious beings, entities in that
realm. In fact, according to Greek
mythology, it was the Titans who when
they were defeated in battle by Zeus and
the gods, they were chained in Tartarus.
Yeah.
You catch the problem, right?
Well, yeah.
Peter is confirming this realm as true.
In other words, just because pagans
believe something doesn't mean it's
false. That
That's why I'm laughing because it's
just like the the irony. We're going to
see something else on this as well a
little bit later. Um something that I
want to bring up because I'm currently
reading uh well, St. Gregory of Niss's
on the soul and resurrection.
Amen.
And there's something he points out in
there that is just well, I'll save that
for when we get to it.
Okay.
What's the next what's the next verse?
Now Jude is the parallel to this Jude.
Who are these angels? Well, the evidence
indicates these are the angels of
Genesis 6. And that's confirmed by his
referencing Enoch. So if you go to Jude,
you're going to read verse 6 and 7 to
see what the sin of these angels was.
And the angels who did not stay within
their own position of authority, but
left their proper dwelling, he has kept
in eternal chains under gloomy darkness
until the day of the great uh until the
judgment of the great day. Just as Sodom
and Gomorrah and the surrounding cities,
which likewise indulged in sexual
immorality and pursued unnatural desire,
serve as as an example by undergoing a
punishment of eternal fire.
Now, you got two problems. Notice it's
parallel to second Peter 2:4. parallel
because Peter and Jude are giving
examples of what God did to wicked
beings in the past as a sure sign.
That's what he's going to do to these
false prophets, false teachers that have
risen. But in verse six, he says
something interesting. The angels did
not stay within their own position
authority. Meaning they left their
realm.
And so what happened? He now kept in
eternal chains in gloomy darkness
awaiting the judgment of the great day.
And according to Peter, they're in
Tarterus.
So they're consciously there after being
destroyed. And then notice what their
sin is. It likens Sodom com committing
the same sin they did. Because look what
it says. Just as Sodom and Gomorrah
surrounding cities, which likewise
indulge in sexual immorality, and
pursued a natural desire. Meaning the
angels committed the same sin of Sodom
Gomorrah. What was the sin of Sodom
Gomorrah? unnatural desire, engaging in
homosexual acts. That means the angels
also engaged in the same kind of
activity, unnatural desires and immoral
sexual behavior. Well, the only story in
Genesis where you find anything remotely
close to the story is the sons of God of
Genesis 6:es 1-4 where the sons of God
saw the daughters of men and entered
them and cohabited with them and got
them pregnant. Which brings you to Jude
14 and 15 because Jude then cites Enoch
where that's exactly the interpretation
given. If you read the first seven
chapters of Enoch, it even tells you who
the sons of God were. Gives you their
names and tells you that they went in
and slept with women and taught mankind
sciences. And when it destroyed, they
were now kept in gloomy prison.
So what does this mean? You got
problems, you Adventists. Because if we
follow the train of thought, we have
Peter and Jude affirming
a reality that would have been known to
their readers. For example, when Peter
mentions Tartarus to the Greeks, they
know Tartarus as an actual abode of the
dead where those who have died are there
consciously alive without their bodies
and in prison. And Peter doesn't correct
that. He takes for granted this is a
real realm. The only thing is that these
gods and goddesses that these pagans
think are in control, they're demons.
They're wrong on that area. And then
Jude references a book that says those
angels are the sons of God of Genesis 6
and they were destroyed in the flood and
now kept in this realm where they are
tormented on the day of judgment. Where
do you get soul sleep out of all of
this? Adventists.
Yeah, but Sam, I'm going to play devil's
advocate here because this is just a
common objection. It says that Sodom and
Gomorrah are used as an example, but
Sodom and Gomorrah aren't still burning
right now. That shows that they're just
annihilated.
Okay? Even if I were to grant the fact
that annihilation is what's going to
take place in the future because we can
have a discussion on does the Bible
teach or not, you forget the point that
they were destroyed on earth, but it
doesn't tell us what happened to their
spirits afterward.
Even if I grant that it's teaching
conditionalism that you won't suffer
forever, that doesn't address the fact
that though Sodom Gomorrah and the
surrounding cities were destroyed on
earth, their bodies were destroyed. The
issue is what happened to their spirits.
Yeah.
Well, in light of what we just read, 1
Peter 3:es 19 to 20, spirits were in
prison. Angels were in Tartarus in
prison in gloomy darkness, day of
judgment. That means though the bodies
were destroyed of these inhabitants of
Sodom and Gomorrah or the people of the
flood, they're still alive as
disembodied spirits in the realm of the
dead. That's number one. Number two,
when we talk about the destruction of
Sodom and Gomorrah, who told you that
they're not still undergoing the
punishment of fire because though they
were destroyed physically on earth,
their spirits would have went to the
place of torment in Hades, just like we
find in Luke 16:22-23 where the rich man
died and he found himself tormented in
the flames of Hades. So, who said their
punishment has ceased?
Yeah. Yeah, and we looked at that back
in part one because we heard them claim
that that's a parable and we talked
about the problems surrounding that. But
I think this is just a good point too,
Sam, to show again why to scriptura is
so important and that you shouldn't make
an argument somewhere that causes you
problems with other texts. Like you have
to understand this text in light of all
of the rest of the texts that scripture
has to say on the subject and not just
vacuously um looking for some sort of
like escape hatch basically.
There you go. So that sorry guys, we
have to take longer to destroy the the
heresies than it takes them to
articulate it. So I'm ready for the next
one by the grace of the spirit.
Let's go.
Let's go to the book of John chapter 17
verse 5. Because when we talk about how
Jesus in his human um nature laid down
his um divinity or laid down his
majesty, I should say. What what exactly
does that mean that he put on human
flesh? In John chapter 17 verse5, the
Bible says, "And now, oh father, glorify
thou me with thine own self, with the
glory which I had with thee before the
world was."
Interesting. So, we understand that
Jesus had to lay aside glory to put on
human flesh. Does that make sense?
Okay.
All right. Now, but what exactly does
that mean? What exactly does it mean
that Jesus laid aside glory to put on
human flesh? Let's go to the book of
Daniel, chapter 7.
Keep in mind that word glory. That's the
key word, glory. Jesus laid aside glory
to put on human flesh.
But let's pay attention to what happens.
Daniel 7:13 it says, "I saw in the night
visions and behold one like the son of
man came with the clouds of heaven and
came to the ancient of days and they
brought him near before him and there
was given him dominion and what what
else was given to him?"
That's glory.
Glory. So in John 17:5
when it said when Jesus is asking the
father give me the glory that I had
before the world began in Daniel 7:14
Daniel is seeing a vision of when Christ
receives that glory from the father.
Does that make sense? But pay attention
to what comes with the glory. It says,
"And there was given him dominion and
glory and a kingdom,
and all people, nations, and languages
should serve him. His dominion is an
everlasting dominion, which shall not
pass away, and his kingdom that which
shall not be destroyed." So when God
um gives Christ the glory, what is he
also giving him?
He's giving him the keys to the entire
universe. He's giving him the kingdom.
the keys to the entire cosmos. So when
Jesus was here on earth having on human
flesh where he had laid aside his glory,
he yielded that um he yielded I guess
the keys or the rights to the entire
cosmos to his father.
Does that make sense?
Amen. Amen.
Boy, this guy.
All right. So, when scripture heretic,
go ahead. Yeah.
So, when scripture talks of Jesus
condescending in the incarnation by
adding unto himself a human nature,
they're claiming that means he set aside
the authority and keys to running the
universe. And then apparently in 1844
when the Adventist Jesus approached the
Ancient of Days, he received that
authority back and started running the
universe again. Because for those that
do not know, the SDA church
organizationally claims that Daniel 7 is
not about the ascension, but 1844 and
the investigative judgment. That Jesus
approached the Ancient of Days on
October 22nd, 1844 to begin the
investigative judgment. And that is
supposedly what Daniel 7:14 is talking
about, which would mean according to
what Deonte just asserted, Jesus didn't
start running the universe again until
1844.
That's right.
And since I know SDAs will try and argue
literally everything I claim and say I'm
making, you know, making stuff up.
Notice this is from SDA pioneer J. And
Andrews on Daniel 7:14. And this is not
a one-off. This is just one example.
quote, "The coming of the anc uh the
coming of the ancient of days in this
vision of Daniel's is not to this world
but to the place of his judgment scene,
the investigative judgment with regard
to the place of this tribunal. We will
speak hereafter." We've already proved
that this uh session of the judgment
precedes the second advent and that it
is not held upon our earth. This fact
establishes the truthfulness of this
proposition.
Close quote.
And yes, this was supposed to be an
alleged vision from Ellen White or
supported by rather. It's supposed to be
supported by an Ellen an Ellen vision,
which means they have God's stamp of
approval that that's what the text is
officially talking about. Adventists do
not understand Daniel 7 is about the
ascension, not 1844 or the second
coming. So Sam, I'm not sure how they
think any of this addressed I don't know
if you remember the clip they played
from you in the the part that they're
responding to here, but it didn't
address anything that you were saying um
other than to try and say, "Well, yeah,
Jesus wasn't running the universe while
he was on Earth."
Yeah, they're obviously confused and
they don't even know what they they mean
or understand the argument. They just
confused Christ enthronement
where he's now on the throne and people
can now recognize who he is with Jesus
still personally sustaining creation.
These guys have confused so many issues.
They are so bad it's even it gets you
angry in your spirit that you have to
answer such dumb pathetically bad
arguments that are even blasphemous. Now
notice, I'm glad he admits that what
it's talking about is Christ
enthronement where he goes and sits in
throne as ruler where he's confused and
I'm going to destroy this in a minute is
he is assuming that if Christ is no
longer in heaven visibly on the throne
where people can now view him and know
who he is. This is God the king on the
throne. If he's not on the throne,
therefore that means he's not personally
sustaining creation. This is a logical
fallacy. The fallacy of false dilemma
and a nonsecary because it does not
follow that if Christ is not enthroned
that somehow means he's now no longer
actively sustaining creation because we
already destroyed that argument. We just
did it now and in part one where Christ
on earth go watch part one is still
omnisient. John 16:25-31,
John 2:23-2
before his death and resurrection as
well as afterwards John 21:17
Jesus is still omnipresent John 1:45-49
John 4:43-54
Mark 7:24-30
go watch part one it's there and Christ
did not cease to be God in all his
fullness while on earth that would be
Colossians 119 to 20 Colossians 2:9 and
so on and so forth. But I'm glad he
admitted it means his enthronement. So
now let me explain what is going on
here. When Christ is on earth, no one
can tell this is the king of creation
who owns creation who's the heir of
creation and everything subject to him
because he veiled that. But now when you
see Christ, you don't see him in a
humble lowly status as a servant. You
see him as the king that he's always
been. But on earth, he didn't come and
manifest that he is the royal king and
everyone is a subject. Why? Because
Jesus tells you. Can you go to Matthew
20:28?
Yep.
So, I don't know how they confuse all
these issues. But I'm glad he admits
it's about him ru ruling as king because
his assumption is if he's on earth in
the form of a servant and he's not
appearing visibly on the throne. Notice
I said visibly because we just showed
that Jesus is still in heaven while on
earth. But the difference is when he's
in heaven before the incarnation, he
would have appeared visibly before he
had flesh. But when he comes down to the
earth and becomes flesh, though he's
still filling heaven and earth,
sustaining it, he's not appearing
visibly in heaven, but he's visibly on
earth in his flesh. And now he's visibly
in heaven again, but this time in flesh
as flesh as man. So let me repeat before
he reads it. Before Christ became flesh,
and I'm going to show you that from
John, he would appear in a visible form
like the father would.
And when you saw him in heaven, you know
you're looking at the king, God
Almighty. But when he became flesh on
earth, he does not appear visibly in
heaven. Not because he's not there, but
because now he's appearing visibly in
that flesh because he's now a man. And
then he returned to heaven as flesh and
now appears as a real man with a
physical body. But just like he can be
physically in heaven and still present
with us and oversee creation. Likewise,
he was on earth in the flesh, but still
present in heaven and sustaining heaven
and earth. It's not either or. These
guys don't know what they're talking
about. So what's the difference? while
he appeared on earth as a servant to
serve and didn't manifest the glory that
we would behold him if he's in heaven by
which we know this is our king. He's not
just a servant. He's our king who has
now humbled himself to serve us. Matthew
20:28.
Even as the son of man came not to be
served but to serve and to give his life
as a ransom for many.
That's what he did. He appeared on earth
to serve. But can't kings still serve
without ceasing to be kings?
Correct. Well, not just that, but
Matthew's already told you back at the
beginning the the wise men that come and
see him, they call him a king as a babe.
He's already born king and they already
worship him. Matthew 2:1. Matthew, where
is he born? King of the Jews. We've seen
a star in East come to worship him.
Matthew 21. They found a child because
he was around two years old in the house
of his mother and they worshiped him and
even the gifts they gave him. If you
look at it, I've done
gold tribute for a king,
incense, labanos, which is what priests
give to God in worship.
Y
and myrr, which is what they use to
prepare bodies for burial. And why they
do that, that's we can
Sam. This is actually an area that I
love because it actually has great
reference made in a book you hardly ever
hear cited and that is the Song of
Solomon
and how there's a connection to those
same things that they brought to being
what uh well he essentially says is like
it makes an aromatic for love and so it
has to do with uh the love of God and
those sorts of things but
glory to God. Maybe one day we'll do
that to show that he was still truly
God. I want you to understand what glory
he's setting aside. The visible glory by
which you know this is no mere ser
servant. He is your king who is coming
to serve. So again the false dichotomy
either or that if he's a servant
therefore he's given up authority and
therefore he's not a king anymore where
it's it's either or. He's still God in
the flesh. He's still personally
sustaining all creation. He's still one
with the father and the spirit
overseeing, preserving, giving life to
all creation. We established that from
Colossians 1:16:17, Hebrews 1 2:3 and so
on and so forth. The difference is he
does not appear on earth in that glory
by which you know this is the king and
he's chosen to serve and not the man to
be served because he's our king. Things
have now changed because now he's on the
throne. Now he's no longer in a humble
lowly status on earth. And now when you
see him, you recognize, wow, that's our
God who's our king. He never stopped
being our God and king, but he humbled
himself not to demand his rights to be
served as king, but served us. And by
the way, if they're talking about 19th
century when Jesus then regained all
authority in heaven and earth, we got a
problem. Matthew 28:18 says, "It was his
even after the resurrection before he
ascended to heaven." Here, Matthew
28:18.
Yeah. All authority in heaven and earth
has been given to me. Go therefore,
baptizing in the name of the father,
son, holy spirit. Yeah. It's the whole
reason that the great commission has any
level of authority is because it's a go
therefore. Well, what's the therefore?
The therefore is he says he has all
authority in heaven and on earth. But I
don't think Deontay made the the
connection to the problem that I was
pointing out. The official
organizational position is that Daniel
7:14 is talking about Jesus approaching
the father in 1844.
He claimed that Jesus receiving the
glory back was receiving the keys to the
universe when he approached the father.
Well, that would have to have happened
in 1844 according to your system. So,
you're saying it wasn't until 1844 that
Jesus received the keys of the universe
back?
Yeah. Now, watch how this
false teaching of the teaching of the
pioneers destroyed because it says even
before his ascension, he already had all
authority in heaven and earth. That's
right. Matthew 2:18, right? What does it
say?
Now, the 11 disciples went to Galilee to
the mountain to which Jesus had directed
them. And when they saw him, they
worshiped him, but some doubted. And
Jesus came and said to them, "All
authority in heaven and on earth has
been given to me. Go therefore and make
disciples of all nations, baptizing them
in the name of the Father and the Son
and of the Holy Spirit,
teaching them to observe all that I've
commanded you. And behold, I am with you
always to the end of the age." earn. So
here he's saying because all authority
in heaven and earth is mine. That's
simply a way of saying every creature
and all creation is mine. Go and
announce to the nations the king is
demanding their allegiance and all who
believe will now obey me and implement
my rule in their life. Those who reject
I will come and punish them. Now let me
show you something ironic. What's his
name? Deante.
Dante. Did you know that Jesus while on
earth says all things were already his?
Deante, have you ever read Matthew
11:27?
Watch. It's going to get worse. So
already on earth, all things were
already his.
All things have been handed over to me
by my father. And no one knows the son
except the father. And no one knows the
father except the son and anyone to whom
the son chooses to reveal him.
Now this is before his death and
resurrection.
Correct. And ever already all things
have been handed over to him.
Yeah. This is during his ministry.
Oh, but now I'm going to shock you
because you're going to see what all
things are. Start from Matthew 11:25 and
read to 27. 11. Matthew 11:25-27. And
that's confirmed in John.
At that time Jesus declared, "I thank
you, Father, Lord of heaven and earth,
that you have hidden these things from
the wise and understanding and revealed
them to little children. Yes, Father,
for such was your gracious will. All
things have been handed over to me by my
father, and no one knows the Son.
Let me show you. Notice in the context,
the father is lord of heaven and earth.
Verse 25. Right?
Yep.
So, if all things have been handed over
to him by his father, contextually, the
all things means everything in heaven
and earth which the father is lord of.
Hm.
Interesting. So, there's a sense in
which Jesus still owns everything while
he's on Earth, huh?
Wow. You see why these guys are
dangerous?
Well, and again, it gets into the
problem of like looking at everything
vacuously.
Yeah. like even so vacuously to where
like you apparently he didn't stop to
even think well we say this about Daniel
7:14 which if I'm going to make this
argument that would mean that I'm having
to say Jesus didn't get you know receive
this until but he actually correctly
recognizes there Daniel 7 is about the
ascension it's not about the second
coming or 1844
it's about the ascension it's Jesus the
cloud rider and the the the incense
going up to the father and a pleasing it
just
all of all of that is pictured there
with the ascension, not 1844.
Okay, let me let's make their sleepless
nights even more extensive because
they're going to have a lot of sleepless
nights. Can you read for me John 16 14-
15? While on earth before he was killed
and crucified,
did all things already belong to him?
And did Jesus own everything that
belongs to the father while on earth
before he died, before he was raised?
Just verse 14. John 16:14 and 15.
He will glorify me for he will take what
is mine and declare it to you. All that
the father has is mine. Therefore, I
said that he will take what is mine and
declare it to you. Is mine already, not
shall be mine.
Correct.
Already? Huh?
All that the father has. So, is there
anything the father doesn't have?
No.
And he already had it. It was his
already. And who's going to convince you
of that? The spirit, right?
Yep.
What about John 17 verse 2 and 10? Then
we can move on. I Man, you guys are bad.
I hope they didn't decide to do another
uh session while we're doing this.
Yeah. I don't know. I don't pay
attention to them.
You guys are pathetically Yeah. John 17
and two. Does Jesus already have all
authority over flesh? And in verse 10,
what does he say? John 17 2 and 10.
since you have given him authority over
all flesh to give eternal life to all
whom you have given him.
And then you said 10
all mine are yours and yours are mine
and I am uh glorified in them.
So already all mine are yours already
and all yours already mine already have
been given authority over our flesh
while he's on earth.
Yeah, but Sam, you're hopscotching
around the Bible now. You didn't read
all the in between verses. There's
something that changes in between these,
you know, two and 10.
Oh, well, show me what it is. Because in
verse five, the glory he's talking about
is the visible glory.
In other words, this is the final point
I'm going to make. Let me explain what
Jesus saying. And I'm going off camera
because I got to look for my cat. Hold
on. Okay, understand. Now, read five for
them. So, now we're because now I'm
going to show you what he meant. He's
not talking about what they think. He's
saying the glory I had, the glory by
which you would see Jesus manifested and
truly know who he is. And I'm going to
prove it from John. But in John 17:5,
what does it say?
And now, Father, glorify me in your own
presence with the glory that I had with
you before the world existed.
Okay, what glory is he talking about?
He's talking about visible. In fact,
here's my challenge everyone. If you
read the term glory in its biblical
context, whether cavod kabad or doxes,
the Greek, you're going to notice it
always refers to something visible,
either a physical visible act of God, a
miracle by which God makes something of
himself known or a visible appearance.
It has to do with visibility like Peter
and Paul and John raising the dead.
Well, that act which is being seen will
now tell us something about God that he
is the author of life or God appearing.
Now, what does it mean? The glory I had
with you which I'll have again. You
don't need to guess. First of all, open
up Isaiah 6 for me if you can.
Yep.
And you're going to read the first five
verses for now. Pay attention who is
seen.
Isaiah 6 1-6
1:5 chapter 6 1-5.
Okay.
In the year that King Uzziah died, I saw
the Lord sitting upon a throne high and
lifted up, and the train of his robe
filled the temple. Above him stood the
seraraphim. Each had six wings, and two
he covered uh two he covered his face,
and with two he covered his feet, and
with two he flew. And one called to
another and said,
"Holy, holy, holy is the Lord of hosts.
The whole earth is full of his glory.
And the foundations of the thresholds
shook at the voice of him who called,
and the house was filled with smoke. And
he said, "Woe is me, for I am lost, for
I am a man of unclean lips, and
I have uh and I dwell in the midst of a
people of unclean lips, for my eyes have
seen the king, the Lord of hosts."
Notice my own physical eyeballs seeing
Yahweh visibly. Right?
Correct. So he sees Yahweh in a visible
shape seated on a visible throne and he
sees the saraphim visibly seeing him
visibly in a visible shape. Now we don't
believe I don't know what they believe
but yeah actually I do. He said because
Jesus uh was asked yeah he has a form
like mine. If you understand the Bible
correctly,
if God created time, space, and place,
created heaven and earth, that means he
is a type of being that doesn't need
space or place to dwell in or exist.
Which means he's a type of being that's
not bodily by his very nature has to be
bodyless. But that God can then assume
and appear in any shape and form. So we
can see invisibly. So I don't believe
that God has always had a shape before
creation. Yeah,
I believe God will assume a shape after
creation so that we can see who by his
very nature is invisible. So here's a
shape that God is appearing by which you
know this is God. He's the king. Pay
attention. The king, right?
Yep.
King, guys, it's about kingship. You're
going to see who this was according to
John in a minute. Now to make the
connection clear who Isaiah was seeing,
whose glory he be beheld, read verses 8
to 10. Isaiah 6 8-10. same chapter.
And I heard the voice of the Lord
saying, "Whom shall I send and who will
go for us?" Then I said, "Here I am.
Send me." And he said, "Go and say to
this people, keep on hearing, but do not
understand. Keep on seeing, but do not
perceive.
Make the heart of this people dull and
their ears heavy and the blind their and
blind their eyes lest they see with
their eyes and hear with their ears and
understand with their hearts and turn
and be healed. Then I said, "How long,
oh Lord?"
Now before that you can stop there
because the Kever is going to be 10. But
reread eight one more time. Okay?
And then 10. Eight. But first read
reread eight.
And I heard the voice of the Lord
saying, "Whom shall I send and who will
go for us?
Then I said, "Here I am. Send me."
Notice the word us right there. Verse
10, not eight.
Yep.
So the God who is I is also us. Whom I
send, go for us. Keep that in mind.
But then verse 10, read what God tells
Isaiah to say. Verse 10. Make the heart
of this people dull and their ears heavy
and blind their eyes lest they see with
their eyes and hear with their ears and
understand with their hearts and turn
and be healed.
Okay, now guys remember that statement.
It is Yahweh God who told Isaiah to say
these words. Yahweh God said go tell the
people these words. Yahweh God who
appeared visibly in a body visibly
seated on a visible throne. And Isaiah
saw this vision of heaven with his
physical eyes. Now according to John
12:37-41,
who did Isaiah see? This is the glory
that Jesus is talking about it. And it's
even said to be his glory that Isaiah
saw
John 12:37-41.
Though he had done so many signs before
them, they still did not believe in him.
so that the word spoken by the prophet
Isaiah might be fulfilled.
Lord, who has believed that he has heard
from us? And to whom has the arm of the
Lord been revealed? Therefore, they
could not believe. For again Isaiah
said, he has blinded their eyes and
hardened their heart, lest they see with
their eyes and understand with their
heart and turn and I would heal them.
Now, what did he just quote, brother,
before you read verse 41? He's quoting
what we just read in Isaiah 6.
Isaiah 6. And here it's talking about
why the Jews rejected Jesus. Right.
Correct.
But now 41. Notice why Isaiah said this.
Isaiah said these things because he saw
his glory and spoke of him.
Whose glory did he see?
Yahweh.
But according to John, who's the glory
that he saw?
12:37.
Jesus.
Whoa. You mean that Yahweh who appeared
visibly in a visible shape? see it on a
visible throne. That's Jesus that Isaiah
saw.
Correct?
And when when he saw him, that's when he
saw his glory.
Correct.
A glory by which Isaiah had no doubt.
This is the king, Yahweh of hosts.
Correct?
That's the glory Jeze is talking about.
The glory by which you'll know this no
doubt is Yahweh the king.
He didn't manifest it on earth because
all they saw was a poor Jewish
carpenter, a flesh and blood Jew.
Yeah. So the point being is it's not
talking about him receiving the keys of
the universe back
precisely because in one sense he's
always been king but another sense he
didn't arrogate himself the privileges
of king but himself to be a servant
without ceasing to be king
you can leave your throne and still be
king man well I mean okay uh son and we
s we find this in history for example
archaeologists confirm the miraculous
accuracy of Daniel 5 because Daniel
correctly notes that when Babylon was
toppled by the Persians, Cyrus, the one
who was acting as king in Babylon, this
ties with the point was the son of
Nebonitis. Historically,
the king of Babylon was Nebonitis, but
he went to Arabia for several years to
worship the moon in Arabia. And he left
his son in charge.
Belshazzer
was left in charge. Now guys, here's how
accurate Daniel is. Because up until
modern discoveries in Iraq, they thought
Ba Daniel was an error because there was
no historian afterwards that mentioned
that when Cyrus conquered Babylon, Iraq.
It was Belshazzer who was acting as king
because his father who was the actual
king went to Arabia to worship the moon.
That's why Belshazzer offers Daniel the
third highest position as kingdom. If
you can interpret the sign on the wall
because Belshazzer was number two.
Now what is my point? When Nebonitis
left to Arabia, he stopped being king of
Babylon.
No.
But according to that logic, if Jesus
left the throne and he came to earth,
he's no longer king. Nor is he the king
who is not acting within his rights as
king but serving humbly and hiding his
identity not because of deceit so that
he could accomplish the will of the
father by dying as a sacrifice.
Yep. Correct. Well, and like we talked
about earlier, you've got Matthew 2,
which clearly says he's a king as a baby
there in Bethlehem. Um,
and onward.
So, I hope that argument went out the
window. I hope you guys get convict and
repent. There's still hope for you guys.
I hope you're not that stubborn. So, we
can go to the next one.
By the way, how many you have,
you know, I want to
um I don't know total. I think about
three or four.
Okay, go ahead, brother. Let's have a
field day.
Answer um this question as well like who
who runs the universe. Um so, the 7th
Day Adventist Church officially in their
second fundamental beliefs believes in
the trinity, the godhead. And what this
basically means is we understand that
the Bible gives the title of God to
three distinct individual persons. Yeah.
The father, the son, the holy ghost.
They all hold the title as God. And so,
you know, uh I'm going to show you a
couple of verses. Um not to get into the
whole trinity discussion because I
understand that that is a a very um
controversial topic, but officially
that's what the church believes. It
says, "God that made the world and all
things therein, seeing that he is Lord
of heaven and earth, dwelleth not in
temples made with hands, neither is
worshiped with men's hands, as though he
needed anything, seeing he giveth to all
life and breath and all things." So what
we got here is that God is the one who's
in charge of everything and hath made of
one blood all nations of men for to
dwell on all the face of the earth and
have determined the times before
appointed in the bounds of their
habitation that they should seek the
Lord if happily they might fill after
him and find him though he be not far
from every one of us. For in him talking
about God we live and move and have our
being as certain of your own poets have
said for we are also his offspring. So,
who runs the universe? Who runs the
world according to this passage? The
answer is God. Right? And here's another
verse to consider. 1 John 5:7. It says,
"For there are three that bear record in
heaven, the Father, the Word, and the
Holy Ghost. And these three are one."
Right?
God. Again, the Bible does prove show
that three persons hold this title. The
Father is God. The Word is God. You can
see that from John 1:1. In the beginning
was the word. The word was with God and
the word was God. Um, so the word is has
a title as God and the Holy Ghost. You
can go to Acts, let me just show that
real quick. Acts chapter 5, it says very
plainly. But Peter said, Ananas, why has
Satan filled thine heart to lie to the
Holy Ghost to keep back part of the
price of the land? Whilst it remained,
was it not in thine own? And after it
was sold, was it not in thine own power?
Why hast thou conceived this thing in
thine heart? Thou hast not lied unto
men, but unto God. So we can see in this
passage lying to the Holy Ghost. The
Bible's telling us when you're lying to
the Holy Ghost, you're not lying unto
men, you are lying to the Holy Ghost. So
again, the Bible is very very plain that
three persons hold this title. Uh
Hebrews chapter uh 1:8, even God the
father is calling the son God. He says,
"But unto the son he saith, thy throne,
oh God, is forever and ever except our
righteousness." So who runs the
universe? God runs the universe. And
that's why you can say Jesus runs the
universe. Yes. The Holy Spirit runs the
universe. Yes. The father runs the holy
the universe. Yes. The answer is yes.
Because all three of them they work
together as one. 1 Corinthians 11:3. But
I would have you know that the head of
every man is Christ and the head of the
woman is a man, and the head of Christ
is God. Now, even though they're all one
in their nature, the Bible also does
make it that Jesus did submit to the
father the because it plainly says the
head of Christ is God. So there there is
a hierarchy there as as far as their
order, but they're still considered one,
but they just have a order of doing
things. Jesus tells us to pray to the
father. They all have different roles
within that godhead,
but they are all equal. Last
All right. So, Sam,
yeah. What's the point, dude? Help me
out.
Well, this is why definitions and
understanding definitions are so
important because what you're seeing put
forth here is that when this
organization and people within this
organization, I know that they are not
official spokesmen for the organization.
These are not scholars. Um,
so I'm I'm not trying to to I'm just
we're using them as an example here. um
when they use terms
they do not mean the same thing we do.
They are trying to essentially say well
God was still running the universe even
if Jesus as a man on earth when he was
dead wasn't doing it because since both
the father and the holy spirit are God
was still running the universe.
They're dividing the Godhead, which is
why back in part one when we talked
about the hypothatic union and their
appeal to that and how on their website
they the organization even tries to say
that and then in the next paragraph they
say he set his divine nature aside. Um
you're seeing though how there is
division at that level. Um they don't
understand the singular being of God.
But now we got an appeal to the
commanium.
First John 5:7. Now Sam, I don't know
your opinion on the uh the Kame
Yahanium. Um but I think you're further
seeing why I I don't take these guys and
their apologetic very seriously.
Since Jason just reiterated basically
the same thing that the other fella did.
Explain for the audience
what the Kama Yahanium is. Yes.
And why it should not be appealed to as
a biblical evidence for the Trinity.
Yeah. Now this is where you're going to
nail them in the future, brother. Notice
they stick with the King James version,
correct?
There's no getting around this. Why?
Because John 3:13 is in the King James
version. It says, "No one has sent to
heaven, but he descended from heaven,
the son of man which is in heaven
stuck." So make sure, brother, if you if
you ever do interact with him, say,
"Don't play Bible ping pong with me
because right here you quoted the King
James Bible. You believe every reading
King James Bible must be inspired and
infallible.
And so that means you're
they don't actually believe scripture is
inherent.
Oh, all right. Well, okay. So, do they
believe every verse they're quoting from
the King James is at least inspired,
preserved?
They they they do believe that, but they
because and this gets into a long
discussion about the writings of Ellen
White. And since there are errors in the
writing of Ellen White, they have to
alter their view of of inherency and
essentially say, well, no, then and
they'll concede that there are are
errors, but that's man's problem. That's
not God's fault. But that's a side
discussion.
Okay. Well, at least you got them, you
got them to stick with the King James.
They believe it's inspired and every
reading there is authoritative because
inspired. They're stuck because you have
John 3:13 saying Jesus is in heaven on
earth at the same time. Physically on
earth, but as God, he's in heaven and
earth. That's number one. Number two, if
you just get any modern Bible and you
look at the note, 1 John 5:7 is not
attested in the earlier Greek copies of
1 John 5. It's found in some later
medieval Greek manuscripts and in some
places it's found in the margin. This is
why if you base your evidence on the
Greek manuscripts,
this is a late medieval reading because
the earlier Greek copies of first John 5
or verse 7 appears does not have there
are three that reckon heaven, the
father, word, the holy ghost. These
three are one. It's not because
trinitarians don't like that passage.
We're trinitarians. It just shows what
he's trying to highlight is they are not
that well read. They are not that very
scholarly because they're going to cite
passages that's going to create problems
in their witness to those who don't
share their assumption. But with that
said, since they take the King James
readings as being inspired as being the
preserved words,
you're stuck because you can put 1 John
57 5-7 aside. You're stuck with John
3:13. Jesus is in heaven and on earth.
Even though physically on earth as God,
he's in heaven and earth at the same
time. Can't have your cake and eat it
too. So I hope that was at least clear
to the audience.
Look at your Bible note. The reading
first John 5:7 is poorly attested among
the Greek copies. The earlier Greek
witnesses that have first John 5 where
verse 7 is found does not have this
reading. It's found in later medieval
Greek manuscripts. very late and in some
places in the margin which is why modern
versions relegate it to a footnote. But
they love the King James. You're stuck
with the King James. So if I quote John
3:13, you better not come and do a
response. Well, that's not found in the
earlier Greek copies. Well, number one,
it has better attestation among the
Greek manuscripts than 1 John 5:7. It's
found some early copies, ancient
Christian writers, ancient versions, and
it's the majority reading of the
majority copies of the Greek New
Testament.
Well, and if they come at you too, not
just that, but they also better remember
their own arguments to see why this is a
problem and not be like, "Well, I we
agree with that." Well, then you just
refuted your own arguments you were just
making here to talk about defending your
position of the state of the dead, which
they got a little bit off track there.
But now they're going to finally get
back on to the topic at hand.
First, I'll share on the subject as far
as who runs the universe. When Jesus was
here on this earth as a man, as a man,
who runs the universe? The Bible says
God does. But what about Jesus? It says
in John 5 15.
Um,
hold on.
Let me just read it.
John 15.
Oh, that's why I'm supposed to go John
5:15. It says this, "The man departed
and told the Jews that it was Jesus
which made him whole." So this is when
Jesus healed, you know, the man. I think
it was on the Sabbath day he did this.
And therefore did the Jews persecute
Jesus and sought to slay him because he
had done these things on the Sabbath
day.
Yep.
But Jesus answered them, what did he
answer them?
My father workketh hitherto and I work.
So what is Jesus saying? The things that
the father does
he does
are also the things that I do.
Let's keep reading.
Yeah.
Therefore, the Jews sought the more to
kill him because not only had he broken
the Sabbath, but said also that God was
his father, making himself what God?
Equal with God.
Equal.
Jesus is straight up saying, I'm equal
with the father. Then answered Jesus and
said unto them, verily, verily, I say
unto you, the Son of man can do nothing
of himself. So if Jesus runs the
universe,
yeah,
who is he seeing run the universe?
The Father.
He tells us the Father. For what things
soever he doeth,
these also doeth the Son likewise.
Come on, preacher. Come on.
For the Father loveth the Son, and
showeth him all things that himself
doeth, and he will show him greater
works than these, that you may marvel.
For as the Father raises up the dead and
quickenth them, even so the Son
quickenth whom he will.
Yeah,
you can't really get clearer statements
in Jesus's mouth about who's really
running the universe. The Father, the
Son, and the Holy Ghost all have their
hand in running the universe. So even if
when rather when Jesus died, you still
had the father and the holy ghost
running the universe because the answer
about who runs the universe is God. What
we believe is that Jesus when he came as
a man he laid he put his uh his glory
his his his godlike powers he put it on
divin divine power on dormant.
Yep. And he was really operating as a
man relying on the father's strength.
When he resurrected, he said, "God, give
me the glory I had before the world
was." He got back all of that glory and
divinity and that power. He he he he he
he took that back on himself. And so
during that time when he was on earth,
we understand that the father and the
holy spirit, they were really running
the universe.
Yeah. This guy just contradict himself.
Yeah. embarrassed himself and he just
proved he's a blasphemer and a heretic.
So, I thought it was interesting
earlier, Sam, because I knew this was
coming up. I knew you didn't. And I
thought, well, this is going to be
interesting because we just looked at
John 5. And does John 5 say what he just
claimed the text is saying that you can
support the idea from John 5 that John's
point is Jesus on earth as a man
was not running the universe
but he could see the father was running
the universe.
Yeah. Now here's what's interesting. He
read it and he just gave it away. But
then he went contradict himself, buried
himself in Deante. You guys hear goes,
"Who does Jesus see really running the
universe?" The father. But he quoted the
verse that says Jesus does whatever the
he sees the father doing. John 5:19,
right?
Yeah. Wow.
Whatever the father does, the son does
in the same manner. That means the very
verse he quoted, which he then agreed,
father, son, holy spirit as a one god
have a hand in running the universe.
That passage shows that if the f the son
sees the father run the universe and the
son does whatever the father does in the
same way he does it that means the son
on earth was still running the universe
because John 5:19 is about the present
reality
on earth on earth I do whatever I see
the father doing and I do it the same
way he does just like he's working on
the Sabbath now that's why I'm working
on on the Sabbath because I work in
perfect union with him. When he works, I
work. So, he works on the Sabbath, I
work on the Sabbath. If he's now working
to run the universe, I'm working to run
the universe. I haven't stopped. You
just annihilated and obliterated your
heresy. But catch the other heresy. Did
you catch it? He says that Jesus as a
man relied on the power of the father.
Well, number one, can you show me where
Jesus on earth was completely dependent
on the father's power in the way in
which he wasn't himself using that power
that he possesses with the father. What
do I mean? Because they don't know
theology. They don't know the Bible. The
father's power is the son's power, the
spirit's power. Why? Because if they're
one god, not three gods, then their
power is one. So the father's power is
the son's power is the spirit's power.
This is why in some places an author
will affirm that Jesus did miracles when
he was anointed by the spirit and power.
Why? Because the context they're talking
to unbelieving Jews. They don't believe
Jesus is God in the flesh. So what
they're going to do is they're going to
start with commonality. We both can
agree Jesus is a man. Yeah. We both can
agree he did miracles. You saw it. Yes.
Well, the miracles he did would have
been the power of God,
right? Yeah. But here, let me let you in
on a little secret. The reason why Jesus
is doing miracles by the power of God
because the power of God is his own
power and the spirit's power because he
too is God. But they don't know
theology. Because they don't know
theology. They they create
contradictions when none exists. And
then notice the blasphemy. Not only did
he take on back the glory, he took on
took back the divinity. Do you hear it?
Correct. Yeah. Yeah. Right. Because like
we looked at last time, like the SDA
church's website says, Philippians 2,
when he set aside his glory,
they mean he set they're they're
affirming the kosis interpretation, the
kotic interpretation that Christ set his
divine nature aside and he was only a
man on earth. Which is why this creates
serious problems for their position.
Because if Jesus was only a man while on
earth and what they teach about death is
sensation of existence aside from as a
memory in the mind of God, then that
would logically follow if you're going
to claim Jesus was fully human. That his
death was identical to our death and he
he ceased to exist for three days. And
that is what is consistent with their
system. But Sam, you mentioned something
really quick that I think needs to get
brought up. I brought this up a couple
weeks ago when we talked about the
Trinity. We were actually looking at
some SDA scholars, not these guys, but
actual scholars, and showing they were
trying to argue with me. They were doing
a response to this platform, and they
claimed that we're trinitarians. We're
trinitarians. And one of the areas I
focused on to show that no, you're not.
Is look at what Ellen White says
regarding
the power of God. You mentioned the
power of God, correct? That it wasn't
the father's power. And then the son's
separate power and the holy spirit's
separate power. But it is a shared
that's why you know
divine power.
Correct. That's why you'll see people
like John of Damascus for example saying
one power one essence one it's all one.
Well notice what Ellen White says here.
She's speaking about at an Adventist
baptism talking about the heavenly trio.
Notice what she says. Those who have by
baptism given to God a pledge of their
faith in Christ and their death to the
old life of sin have entered into
covenant relation with God. The three
what?
Powers.
Powers
damn
of the Godhead, the father, son, and
holy spirit are pledged to be their
strength and their efficiency in their
new life in Christ Jesus. Now people can
go check out that stream for themselves.
We looked at five or six statements
where she's the three powers powers
powers multiple plural powers over and
over. It's not just one-offs, but they
don't understand that in their system.
And as you can see from their own
prophetus, this is after the Desire of
Ages. 1898's when when they're supposed
to have it all buttoned up. It's all
been ironed out and figured out at that
point. Okay. Well, this is almost a
decade after that book is out. And here
she is talking about the heavenly trio
as three distinct powers.
My goodness. Yeah, these guys believe in
three gods and one God is greater in
divinity than the other two. That's the
father. Because if you go back and watch
his sessions he did with me and watch
the channel, you guys, I'm trying to get
you to come learn. He's done sessions
where pretty much Jesus was made
almighty.
Correct.
So, he wasn't always almighty. So, they
have three gods and the father is a
greater God than the son and the spirit.
They're tritheists. They're not
trinitarians.
And
the devil rejoiced when man fell.
Because if you remember in the great
controversy, the claim is that the earth
was created in the great controversy
where God is accu or Satan is accusing
God of being unfair, his law not being
fair, impossible to be kept.
The earth is then created by the father
and son after this act of exaltation
where they're then going to create the
earth and put humans on the earth and
they're going to be put on a
probationary period in the great
controversy to test this claim. And when
Satan was able to make man fall or cause
man to fall, he rejoiced. She says
because why?
He was able to pull he knew he would be
able to pull Jesus down from his exalted
status and he would have to come as a
man and then he would tempt Jesus when
he was on earth as a man and cause him
to stumble and fall. So this whole
setting aside of his divinity and his
glory and the stuff that they're saying
if we go and look at their authoritative
source documents which include Ellen
White in this whole narrative it's not
just that he set his divinity aside.
It's that he set aside what was bestowed
on him in the exaltation, him being
almighty. So he was exalted to be made
equal with the father, but then when he
incarnates, he sets that aside and then
never truly takes it back on because
what did we read earlier in physical
human form, which they believe he will
forever have, the adventist Jesus, he's
not actually omnipresent.
The spirit is how he he never received
that omnipresence back. That was
something he's eternally surrendered.
And so I've heard Adventists actually
appeal to this to say, look how much he
loved us. He was willing to give up
omnipresence, you know, and take on and
be a human forever to save us.
And let me further add why these are
blasphemies and these are blasphemers.
You guys understand
God's nature is unchangeable.
God's nature is incorruptible.
And because God's nature is unchangeable
and corruptible, it doesn't increase and
decrease. And God's nature encompasses
certain essential characteristics,
attributes. Okay? Here they're telling
you that Jesus can cease to be almighty,
cease to be omnipresent, cease to be
omnisient, and cease to exist. Which
means in their view, they cannot be
necessary characteristics of the divine
nature. Because if you can lose them,
that means these are not necessary
qualities for someone to possess if he's
truly God. So then what is God to them?
Yeah. It's like a familial
to exist.
It's like a familial title. It's not
they they do not understand the one
being and why that's so important and
why I constantly hammer on that.
Adventists will want to say, "Well, we
believe that God is three persons,
right? And and but what about being?"
And then you'll get these scholars like
I was responding to a few weeks ago and
we're going to get into again in another
few weeks and finish that out. Um they
tried to say in there, well, we believe
God is three persons, one being. Well,
then that puts you in a pickle because
you either have to condemn your
prophetus and your official source
documents like the review and herald,
the signs of the times, etc. Or you have
to say, well, no, okay, it's not one
being because I can show you official
source documents from Ellen White
receiving the stuff from Vision.
Multiple beings. She says plural beings.
And when I was on your channel, this was
again like a year and a half ago, I
showed on their website
adventist.org/trinity.
It says that at 7th Adventist Christians
believe that God is three beings. And it
went on to say whatever. Well, they've
since changed that. Um there was some
back and forth between me and some other
individuals um that contacted me about
this when I brought it up in a video.
And the excuse was, well, that wasn't
looked at by our theologians. That was
like the slip of a keystroke. So now
they've changed it to say three persons
but nothing about the being of God. And
this is why because in Adventist
theology you can't really have an
ontological oneness with the great
controversy theme. It's just not
possible. Like the whole central thing
is around Lucifer becomes Satan by
becoming jealous of Jesus being exalted
to be made equal with the father. And
that's why the great controversyy's
raging on and their whole worldview and
system is based around the great
controversy. So, it's like you think the
thing that triggered the great
controversy is a little important. I
mean, you can't even have the whole
thing without that first domino. And so,
it creates serious blunders and a
catch22 for their system. Um, so there's
really no way for them to effectively be
actual trinitarians. So, they have to
boil it down to, well, it's just this
general idea that if you believe that
God is three persons. Well, no, a
tritheist could say that.
You're not specific enough to
distinguish the one true God from these
other false idols.
Yeah. Yeah. It's blasphemous. This is
not Christianity, folks. May they
repent. But yeah, so he contradicts
himself and then he admits that Jesus
did not have divinity. He took back
divinity after resurrection. So they're
blasphemers because Jesus is not truly
God because he can cease to exist, cease
to possess these essential qualities
that are definitional nature of God. You
guys are not Christians, guys. But
anyway,
all right, let's get back into this.
All right, so shall we get back to it
because there's a lot to cover and that
was just the first question.
Let's do it.
The Quran both agree that physical death
does not mean you cease to consciously
live. Both the Bible and the Quran agree
that when you die, your physical body
returns to the dust, but you continue to
exist consciously
in the case of the Bible as a
disembodied spirit or soul because the
Bible says that human beings have a
spirit. Human beings have a soul. Now,
so he said that the Bible and the Quran
both agree. I I'm sorry. I I don't know
much about the Quran, so I can't answer
what the Quran says. But he says, "The
Bible and the Quran agree that physical
death does not mean you cease to
consciously live." Both agree that when
you die, your physical body returns to
the dust, but you continue to exist
consciously in the case of the Bible as
a disembodied spirit or soul. So, I
thought, does the Bible I thought we
should answer this question. Does the
Bible really teach that you're conscious
after death as a disembodied spirit or
soul? I mean, I've already given some of
the verses, but what do you guys say?
Uh, let's see what the Bible says. Can
we go to Ezekiel chapter 18?
Let's go to verse four.
So, the Bible says, "Behold, all souls
are mine. As the soul of the father, so
also the soul of the son is mine. The
soul that sinnth, it shall do what?"
Die.
Shall die.
The soul that sinnth it shall die. Does
the Bible teach that when we, you know,
die, we become disembodied spirits?
Or does the Bible teach that we really
die when we die?
Uh let's look at another verse. Uh these
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse 5.
Mhm.
And this is going to be the memory
verse. It says, "For the living know
that they shall die, but what do the
dead know?
No.
Neither have they any more of reward,
for the memory of them is forgotten.
Also their love and their hatred to all
their emotions. Their love, their
hatred, their envy is now perished.
Neither have they any more portion
forever uh forever in anything that is
done under the sun. The living know
nothing. I'm sorry. The dead know
nothing.
Now, let's see what Jesus says. Let's go
to John chapter 14, verse three.
All right. Before we go to John 14, they
brought up Ecclesiastes 9:5 again,
folks. You can go back to part one. That
was absolutely decimated.
Um, but operating on that assumption,
Ezekiel 18:4. Okay, we've got a new
verse here, Sam.
Ezekiel 18 allegedly proves that man is
a monist creature, a a composite being
of breath and a body with no immaterial
conscious aspect to our being. And since
Ezekiel 18:4 says the soul that sins
shall die,
that has to mean you don't have any sort
of immaterial aspect to your being. Bet
you haven't heard that one before. You
just got the smackdown, right?
Never heard. You guys notice what they
did again and go watch part one. We
thoroughly demolished their pathetic
arguments about death. Notice they again
assumed death has to mean non-existence.
So that if the soul dies,
soul dies, that means it ceases to
exist. If the soul dies, it ceases to
exist. So this again shows they don't
know how to refute arguments because you
can't assume what you've yet to prove.
Don't assume death means secession of
life. Prove it.
I'm aware of Ezekiel 18. I use Ezekiel
18, but I don't assume that if the soul
dies, it ces exist. Because here, soul,
read it. It's not about the person. And
this is what we call the etmological or
root fallacy. They're assuming that
words can only have one meaning or it
has a predominant meaning
when in reality even their lexical
sources which they cited. Go back in
part one.
Yeah.
The term soul can have a broad range of
meaning. At times it can refer to you
the person. Bless the Lord oh my soul.
Right?
It can refer to the person. So here so
means the person that sins shall die.
Read it because it talks about that the
sin of the fathers will not fall upon
their children but each man will be put
to death or live because of his or her
own righteousness. So the father's
iniquity will cause the fathers to die
and the sons will not be put to death
for the sins of the fathers. Here soul
means the person. But if they keep
interpreting the Bible in this manner,
they're going to cont create
contradictions galore because you have
passages in which it says that a body
can be put to death and yet the soul
still be alive. We mentioned that
Matthew 10:28. What did Matthew 10:28
say?
Jesus says, uh, you know, don't fear him
who can only kill the body and do
nothing else. Fear him who can cast or
kill both soul and body in hell.
Yeah. And he says literally do not fear
who fear him who can kill the body but
not the soul. Rather fear the one who
can destroy both body and soul in hell.
Now someone said hold on Jesus why are
you distinguishing body and soul? Don't
you know that if you kill the body you
kill the soul? Why are you saying that
the body can be killed and the soul
remain unharmed? And God has the power
to kill both body and soul. You see this
is what they do. They will create
contradictions in scripture when there
are none if you allow the context to
define the range of meaning. Look up any
dictionary for any word. For example,
the word pig, just give you English
terminology. Over 100 years ago, the
word pig did not contain the entry
policeman, a cop. Go read your modern
dictionaries today. One of the meanings
for pig is cop because they're called
pigs. Or if we go back over 100 years
ago, I could call Miles gay because it
meant he's happy and gleeful. Today,
gay, if I don't qualify, it would mean
he's homosexual.
See what they're doing? They do not know
how to interpret scripture. They will
pit scripture against scripture and
create contradictions when none exists.
Another example, Genesis 35:18. It says
that Rachel
was giving birth to Ben O on and her
soul was departing which resulted in her
body dying. Notice the soul was
departing her which resulted in her body
dying. Or in James 2:26 the body without
the spirit is dead. So again, these guys
are a bunch of amateurs, but go ahead,
brother.
And we looked at that in part one, and
we are actually going to end up looking
at that because they're going to cite
that so much of what you're saying, Sam.
I'll be curious to hear what you say in
a couple of clips because they're going
to appeal to a number of these verses
and you're going to get to hear them
interact with them. But again, folks,
it's always interesting when Adventists
will point to stuff like this. The SDA
claim is that the soul is a combination
of breath and a body. When the two
separate, the soul no longer exists. And
I mentioned in part one, the analogy
they love to use is nails and boards. If
you have a pile of boards and a pile of
nails, you have those two things. But if
you put them together, you get a box.
The board and the nails are obviously
still there, but the box is only there
when you put the two together. The soul
is like the box. Breath and body are
like the nails and boards. Take them
apart. soul s so uh no longer exists.
Now I mentioned earlier I'm currently
reading uh Gregory of Niss's on the soul
and resurrection and he actually points
out a very similar analogy
that he dealt with from Epicurans
those who Paul mentioned in the book of
Acts. So for those unaware this book
essentially what it is because when I
read the quote you'll need to know this
Gregory wrote this book after his mentor
St. Basil died. He was wrestling with
the pain he felt from this and he sought
to write out what he believes scripture
teaches on both the nature of the soul
and the resurrection. And he wrote it in
a common format of the day which was a
dialogue between a pupil and a teacher.
So that's what the quote is essentially
part of. Notice what he says here.
So the student asks the teacher, "What
if when we die the soul ceases to exist?
which is essentially the Adventist
claim. Gregory then writes, "My teacher
groaned softly at my words and said,
'The Stoics and Epicurans might have
brought forth these words and others
like them when they met the Apostle Paul
in Athens. For indeed, I hear Epicurus
especially was led in this direction by
his assumptions. He conceived the nature
of beings to be for uh fortuitous and
automatic because he believed there was
no providence pervading events. In
consequence, therefore, he thought by
some kind of breath from our body, as
long as breath is held in by its
container, but when the swollen bubble
bursts, then the contents are
extinguished along with it. For him,
appearance was what defined the nature
of beings. And he made perception the
standard by which all things are
comprehended.
Close quote. So, Epicurus, an actual
pagan, used a bubble as an analogy for
the soul and that when it pops and the
air leaves, the bubble no longer exists.
So, it is just like the Adventist boards
and nails analogy. Yet you will hear
Adventists, we saw it at the beginning
uh in part of part one, but we could go
far more in depth on that and show more
sources. Adventists will try and point
uh to the classical Christian
understanding of the soul and claim that
it's pagan and Satan inspired deception
when in reality it's the Adventist view
that's actually like actual pagans that
ancient Christians like Gregory of Nissa
had to defend Christianity against. This
also disproves, by the way, folks, their
silly myth, the SDA churches, um, that
the classical Christian teaching is a
product of the Middle Ages, concocted up
by the Roman Catholic Church. Not only
because Gregory wrote this before the
Middle Ages, but he's a Capidocian
father of the East, not the West. So,
Adventists, that claim, um,
you who those that claim this, they they
just folks understand they don't know
what they're talking about. If you ever
hear this claim, I hear it all the time.
We've looked at it before. John Lomang,
for example, he's on 3ABN getting
blasted out on satellite TV and he's
saying this claim. This this deception
of the the immortality of the soul is a
is a pagan concept that crept in through
the Roman Catholic Church in the Middle
Ages. No, they don't know what they're
talking about. All right, next clip.
So Jesus said, "And I go,
well, let's start from verse two. In my
father's house there are many mansions.
If it were not so, I would have told
you.
I go to prepare a place for you.
And if I go to prepare a place for you,
I will come again and receive you unto
myself, that where I am, there ye there
ye may be also.
Isn't that interesting?
Yeah.
So, when people die, do they
automatically go to heaven? Or does the
Bible say right here that we have to
wait until the second coming of Christ
for Christ to re receive us into his
kingdom?
Second coming of Christ.
We wait until the second coming of
Christ. The only exception are those
whom the Bible says went to heaven such
as Moses, um Elijah, Enoch.
There you go. Sam refuted annihilate
him.
Bet you haven't read John 14 before.
Jesus said that when he went to prepare
a place for his people and he'll come
again to receive them unto himself.
What a lie.
Which proves that man is a monest
creature only breath in a body with no
immaterial conscious aspect to our being
that can exist apart from the body. And
that proves that
you have to just soul sleep essentially.
Yep. I I wish you guys were men enough
to debate me because what you did to
this passage, shame on you in front of
your eyes. Deante, you are a son of
Satan and I thank the Lord has used me
to expose you. May God shut your mouth
and expose you. And I hope you three men
are man enough to take me on. You just
lied about this passage because the
second coming, Jesus doesn't take you to
be where he where he is. Because the
second coming is when Jesus returns to
the earth, reigns on earth, and heavenly
Jerusalem comes down. But because your
Bible butcher tools of the devil, it's
in front of you and you misquote it. Now
brother, open up John 14 for me. This
refers to Jesus coming to take you at
death, physical death. Read for me
verses 1 to4 slowly.
Let not your hearts be troubled. Believe
in God. Believe also in me.
In my father's house are many rooms. If
it were not so, would I have told you
that I go to prepare a place for you?
And if I go to prepare a place for you,
I will come again and will take you to
myself
that where I am, you may be also.
And you know the way to where I am
going. Now, pause right there, brother.
Now, pay attention. Work with me. Number
one, at the second coming, according to
Revelation 21, Jesus will return to the
earth. Right.
Correct.
And heavenly Jerusalem will come down to
the earth. Right. Correct.
So why would Jesus need to come and take
you to be where he is when he's coming
down to meet us on earth?
Well, exactly. And not just that, but in
the parable of the kingdom in Matthew,
it says when Jesus returns, it's to
throw the wicked out of his kingdom.
Kingdom
and the righteous will inherit the
earth. So what does that say about the
kingdom?
Yep. So the point is he lied. It's not
second coming. Shame on you. That's what
Muslims do. The Lord rebuked you to
repent. He says, "I'm going to take you
to be where where I am. So you'll be
with me where I am." And when at second
coming, he doesn't take us to be with
him. We come down with him to the earth
and our bodies come out of the grave and
we will reign on earth. 1 Thessalonians
4:13:18. But let me show you where Jesus
is and where we will be before his
second coming. They read John 17:5. Now
do me a favor, brother. Read John 17:5
and 24.
Wow, that's I could not
handle their butchering of this passage.
Shame on you guys. Shame on you. May the
Lord use me to expose you. John 17:5,
read,
"And now, Father, glorify me in your own
presence with the glory that I had with
you before the world existed."
Did you remember they admit this is his
enthronement?
Yeah. Earlier they tried to appeal to
this.
Okay. Now, do they now believe he's
reigning in heaven and he's enthroned?
So, I can't speak for them as
individuals, but I do know the official
position on this one. Ellen White also
received a vision on this, so they're
going to be in quite a pickle if they
want to disagree.
No, he is not. They will pay lip service
to saying Jesus is king, but no. And I
will debate any Adventist scholar out
there in the world on this if they want
to deny it. and we will go right to the
sources and I will have them explain
then because this is foundational to the
system. We just looked at this three
weeks ago folks for those that saw it.
We were listening to Stephen Bour. What
did we look at? The vision says right
now Jesus is functioning as a high
priest only in a heavenly tabernacle
building. That's what he started in 1844
with the investigative judgment. And
what Daniel 7 is supposed to be talking
about is that that's when Jesus began
the investigative judgment 1844.
At the close of the investigative
judgment, Ellen White was shown that
Christ, the Adventist Jesus, will take
off his priestly garments, which she saw
him wearing Levitical garments. To which
their scholars such as Roy Gain have
tried to respond by saying, "Well, we
know he's not after the order of Levi.
It's just a picture for for her to see
the function that he's doing. It just
represents the function of a priest."
Well, in the future, she was shown that
he will take off the priestly garments
and put on his kingly garments. He will
cease functioning as a priest. It is not
a simultaneous dual role like the order
of Melkazedc is a kingly priesthood. He
will take off his priestly garments. He
will put on his kingly garments and he
will then come to execute the role of a
king by annihilating the wicked. So no,
in the system he isn't actually
functioning as a king yet because they
teach that the investigative judgment is
where Jesus is seeing who is worthy to
be a part of his kingdom and his kingdom
is the people. And so because that is
still being determined right now in the
investigative judgment. Jesus does not
have the kingdom yet. When he approached
the father in Daniel 7, that was to go
begin this judgment to see who's worthy
and then he'll receive them at the end
of that.
So in other words, though John 17 is
talking about Jesus returning to heaven
after his resurrection and ascension,
they're still going to deny it. Huh? But
for us who let the Bible speak and not
some false prophetess and her views,
notice Jesus says, "Now, Father, glorify
me in your presence with the glory that
I had with you before the world
existed." Now read John 17:24.
Because the plain reading of this
passage, when Jesus went to heaven
physically, bodily, he's now alongside
the father in the same glory. Well,
guess where we will be until the Lord
returns if we are believers united to
Christ. What does John 17:24 say?
Father, I desire that they also whom you
have given me may be with me where I am
to see my glory that you have given me
because you loved me before the
foundation of the world. So, it's the
same thing as verse five. The glory I
had with you before the world was. And
those you've given me, I want them to be
with me where I am to see my glory. The
glory you gave me because you love me
from before the world. Well, Jesus is in
heaven glorified. And Jesus says,
"That's where I want them to be with me
in this glory I have with you." So they
can see your love for me because you've
been loving me from before the world.
That means now we go back to John 14
because nobody says where I am. Since
Jesus is in heaven now and he's
glorified with the father now and Jesus
wants us to be with him to see his glory
as proof that the father loves him. John
14:1-4 again in light of what we just
read.
Let not your hearts be troubled. Believe
in God. Believe also in me. In my
father's house are many rooms. If it
were not so, would I have told you that
I go to prepare a place for you? And if
I go and prepare a place for you, I will
come again and will take you to myself
that where I am, you may be also.
And you know the way to where I am
going. Thomas said to him, Lord, we do
not know where you are going. How can we
know the way?
You can pause there, brother. So he's
going to come to take them to be with
him where he is not. He's coming to the
earth and bringing them to the earth.
That second coming he comes to the earth
here. It's not he's coming to the earth.
He's saying no I'm coming for you Peter,
James, John, Thomas, and I'm going to
come and take you to be with me where I
am. what we just read in John 17. He's
in heaven with the father and that's
where they're going to be. Where did
they get second coming from this?
Do you understand everyone? It's not
referring second coming because second
coming Jesus doesn't come to take us
where he is. He's coming to the earth.
We'll be on earth in that time when
Jesus returns.
So that means he's not going to take us
to heaven because he's going to bring
heaven to the earth.
Yeah. Yeah,
that doesn't make sense.
And again, in conjunction with this,
Jesus's own teaching in the parable of
the kingdom, one of the many, he says
when he returns, it is to throw the
wicked out of his kingdom. So, what
you're describing in the second coming
and what is being described here, um, he
he's Yeah. He's conflated two different
events basically.
Yep. Exactly. And he's referring to
Matthew 13:37-43.
Were the angels are not to throw out of
his kingdom on earth who the
sons of Satan the planting of the enemy
of the owner of the field. So number
one, you butchered this text. God have
mercy on you and rebuke you to repent.
But secondly, we have a problem. Jesus
said, "Those who believe in him can
never die, will never die." Can you read
for me John 11:25-26? I want to tie
these points in as well.
John 11
25-26
through 26. Yep.
And he said Moses is in heaven because
of Matthew 17
verse three and four. I'm going to
challenge you. Show me anywhere in the
scriptures that said Moses was in
heaven. Yes, Moses was alive, but it
didn't say heaven. You butchered the
scriptures again. And I know you're
going to misquote second Kings to
assuming that when Elijah was taken up
in chariots of fire and he went up to
heaven, it means heaven where God
dwells. No, heaven means sky. Elisha saw
him take off in the sky. But we know you
wouldn't know scripture. But anyway, now
John 11:25-26.
Jesus said to her, "I am the
resurrection and the life. Whoever
believes in me, though he die, yet shall
he live. and everyone who lives and
believes in me shall never die. Do you
believe this?
Notice if you're living now and you
believe, you shall never die. Okay? Go
to John 8. Read for me 50- 54. I'm
sorry. John 8, read from 50 to 53.
Okay.
Yet I do not seek my own glory. There is
one who seeks it, and he is the judge.
Truly, truly, I say to you, if anyone
keeps my word, he will never see death.
The Jews said to him, "Now we know that
you have a demon." Abraham died as did
the prophets. Yet you say, "If anyone
keeps my word, he will never taste
death. Are you greater than our father
Abraham, who died, and the prophets
died? Who do you make yourself out to
be?"
Now, notice these Jews are understanding
death the way these Bible butchers are
understanding death, right? Well,
Abraham died. But you say, "Whoever
believes in you and keeps your word
never dies." Never dies. All right? So,
if I believe in Jesus, keep I cannot
die. I will never die. We're going to go
by their definition. Death means ceasing
to exist. They just prove Jesus is a
liar because everyone believes in Christ
dies until he comes and they cease to
exist. That's why they're having a
problem with him. But wait, Abraham
died. Prophets died. But you're saying
someone who believes in you will never
die because they're assuming he's
referring only to the physical.
Yeah.
But then let's go to John 5:24. We're
going to make the burial even further.
John 5:24.
Truly, truly I say to you, whoever hears
my word and believes him who sent me has
eternal life. He does not come into
judgment, but has passed from death to
life.
You know, help me understand the logic.
They're defining death as secession of
life. Okay? Now guys, notice Jesus said,
"If you're alive and you believe me,
you'll never die. Whoever keeps my word
will never die. You pass from death into
life." And they define death. Remember,
soul that sin shall die. Remember, they
define that means you cease to exist.
Jesus said, "You cannot die if you have
my word." But we all die physically.
That means either Jesus is wrong or
their view of death is wrong. Because
Jesus is not simply talking about
physically not dying. He's talking about
not entering into judgment, being
severed from life and fellowship with
God. Because once you're united to God,
you will forever live in his presence,
even without your body. Which is why
John 14 says, "I will come and take you
to be with me where I am."
Now let's go to Luke 20 37-38.
You understand? You got the point,
right, brother?
Yeah.
Luke what?
3738.
Also too, just in conjunction with that,
and I point this out a lot too, Sam, but
I think it's beneficial for people who
may not have heard this. Um if you have
eternal life like Jesus just said there
um it would not be eternal life to say
you have it now but then you cease to
exist and then you'll come back again
there was a gap in there that's not uh
that's not eternal life
and why that can't be because then what
distinguishes unbelievers and believers
now we all die and cease to exist
according to him so what advantage is it
right that right well you'll come back
in the first uh you know the
resurrection the good resurrection
yeah but the whole point what Jesus
saying is you'll never die. Period.
If right Jesus was defining death the
way they do, yeah, we do die. We cease
to exist. But you said we'll never die.
Yeah. Right.
Right. You'll never taste death. You
will never die.
And they're going to they're going to
pull up their favorite verse to try and
refute this and I'll save that for when
we get to it. Luke 20:37-8 it says, "But
that the dead are raised, even Moses
showed in the passage about the bush
where he calls the Lord the God of
Abraham and the God of Isaac and the God
of Jacob. Now he's not God of the dead
but of the living for all live to him."
Now we got another blasphemy from these
Bible butcher. The context is Jesus is
arguing with the Sadducees who denied
the resurrection. We mentioned that in
Acts 23:6-9.
Show them Acts 23:6-9. And they were
trying to trap Jesus. Watch here. Yeah,
these guys are very bad, man. Wow. Very
bad. It's sad. Now, you say, "Well,
they're not officially, you know,
scholars." Well, I hope your church
condemns you because you just
embarrassed your church. Anyway, in Acts
23:69, the Sadducees did not believe in
resurrection. Did not believe there were
spirits that continue exist apart from
the body. Didn't even believe in angels.
They believe you die. You cease to
exist. And they're trying to catch
Jesus. But I'll get to that in a minute.
Acts 23:6-9.
Now when Paul perceived that one part
were Sadducees and the other Pharisees,
he cried out in the council, "Brothers,
I am a Pharisee, a son of Pharisees. It
is with respect to the hope and the uh
and the resurrection of the dead that I
am on trial." And when he had said this,
a dissension arose between the Pharisees
and the and the Sadducees, and the
assembly was divided. For the Sadducees
say that there is no resurrection, nor
angel, nor spirit, but the Pharisees
acknowledge them all. Then a great
clamor arose, and some of the scribes of
the Pharisees party stood up and
contended sharply. We find nothing wrong
in this man. What if a spirit or an
angel spoke to him? Now understand, Paul
is saying, I believe
these doctrines and I confirm them even
as an apostle. meaning that Jesus and
his followers confirm the Pharisees are
right. There are spirits and angels and
there's a resurrection of the dead. But
here the spirits cannot mean angelic
spirits because they're distinguished
from angels. So what spirits could they
be talking about? The spirits of the
human dead.
So notice what the affair is saying. If
a spirit of someone dead came to him,
big deal. If an angel came to big deal,
they exist.
These guys are arguing like the
Sadducees because your soul is you, your
spirit is you or whatever it is. So when
I die, my soul sees exist. Paul did not
believe that. The Sadducees believe
there is no soul separate from the body
or spirit separate in the body. You die,
that's it. Put you are your soul. You
are your spirit. You die, you cease to
exist. Paul says, I don't agree with
that. That's wrong. I agree with the
Pharisees because here they're right.
And Jesus confirmed they're right. There
are spirits. There are angels. So the
spirits are not angels. Then who are
they? The spirits of the dead. And we
went through that last week when Saul
saw the spirit of Samuel. And then
second Mcabes 15 11-17. There Judas had
a vision where he sees the spirit of
Onias who had been killed. And then
Jeremiah's spirit alive and conscious
and alert. Luke 16:19-31.
Abraham, Lazarus, and the rich man,
they're as spirits, their bodies dead,
and Moses and Elijah. You guys are Bible
butcher. But what's the point? The
Sadducees who don't believe, there's a
resurrection. They're trying to catch
Jesus. This is the context of Luke 20.
So, go back to Luke 20. Open up 37:38 to
give you the context. They are now
arguing with Jesus's enemies over
against Jesus and contradicting Jesus.
They are now arguing
against Jesus and siding with his
enemies. Why? Because in Luke 20, the
context is this. The Sadducees wanted to
trap Jesus. They use what's called the
lever law. It's all in Luke 20. You can
read.
They tell Jesus according to the lever
law Deuteronomy 25:5-10 if Miles gets
married dies childless his brother has
to come sleep with his widow get her
pregnant so that now that child will be
credited to Miles to preserve his line
because if he died childless his name
vanishes so if I'm his brother I have to
know perform my brotherly duty marry
marry her have sex with her she gets
pregnant. That first child is his.
Now the Sadducees say, "Well, one man
married this woman, died childless. Then
his brother married her. He died
childless." Seven brothers married her
and they all died without siring any
children. In the resurrection, whose
wife shall she be? Now, I got to unpack
this. I know we're taking too long, but
it's important. Now, here is Jesus, the
master apologist and the master teacher.
theologian and plyacist. Notice he's
going to appeal to Exodus
3:6. Now, he could have quoted Daniel
12:2 where talks about those who asleep
in dust shall awaken, some to eternal
life, others to eternal shame and
contempt. He could have quoted Isaiah
26:19,
where God will raise the dead or Isaiah
25:6-9. But remember the Sadducees
accept the five books of Moses. They
don't believe in the rest of the books.
So where did what did Jesus do? He met
them where they're at. He met them where
they're at. He quoted the books they
accept. Exodus 3:6 because they accept
Moses to show them from that passage
they don't know God or the power of God.
They don't understand the scriptures.
And he says, "When Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob had died physically, and then God
appeared to Moses 400 years later in the
bush, which was Jesus, the angel of the
Lord, and he says to him, I am." Present
tense, not I was. I am the God of your
fathers, the God of Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob. Jesus's point is God would not
have claimed to be the God of Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob 400 years later if they
did not exist because God is not the God
of the dead. God is not the God of
nothing. Because according to them,
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob don't exist.
So, they aren't nothing. That's
blasphemous. He's only the God of those
who live.
So now you Adventist, you just made
Jesus a terrible exedite or a liar
because Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob do did
cease to exist. So that means according
to you, God is the God of the
non-living, those who don't exist
because they've ceased to exist.
Contradicting Jesus's very own argument.
Yeah. See, and I don't think they they
catch that that but Jesus's point there
is
well it's very simple. Was Jesus
Abraham's God
or is Yahweh Abraham's God?
Yes. All right. Abraham is living.
And why is that?
Because he's the God of the living.
Not of non-living things. Things that
don't exist. Correct. But in their view,
Abraham would have to have ceased to
exist aside from as a memory in the mind
of God.
Now, I wanted you to ask them to go to
Matthew 22:31:132 to read the parallel.
Now, watch here, guys. Look how deep it
gets.
Watch here.
Matthew 21
22 31:32. Now, everyone getting this? I
hope you are because I know you guys are
engaging trolls in the comment section,
but
you say, you said, sorry, Matthew 21
what?
No, 22 31. This is the parallel to the
story. Yeah. Now, I hope you understood
what I'm saying. I know you guys are
busy in their channel. They got trolls
are debating, but that's okay. It's
archived. They can go back listen. Watch
again how they just destroyed Jesus's
argument, either proving Jesus didn't
know what he's talking about, or they're
the ones who are citing against Jesus
with his enemies, and they don't know
what they're talking about.
And as for the resurrection of the dead,
have you not read what was said to you
by God? I am the God of Abraham
and the God of Isaac and the God of
Jacob. He is not God of the dead, but of
the living. So, here we go, folks.
Jesus's point is God would never
acknowledge himself as a God of
non-living things, things that do not
live anymore. And yet, that's exactly
what they believe Jesus means when he
says, "I am now." Now that Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob are dead. The God of
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob, he's
basically saying, "I am God of the
non-living because they're not alive."
But Jesus says, "No, that's not
possible." God will never say, "I am the
God of non-living things." And he's
using that to show the Sadducees they're
wrong about death, the nature of death
and resurrection. How How does this
prove the resurrection? Well, Jesus is
saying for God to still be the God of
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob, they're still
alive. And that's Luke 16:19-31,
which we discussed last week. Abraham,
though physically dead, is still alive
in the realm of the dead. Lazarus dead,
he's still alive because their bodies
die, not their souls. Confirming Genesis
15:15, where God says to Abraham, I will
gather you to your fathers in peace and
then you'll be buried. So, you're going
to go to where your fathers are, but
then you'll be buried, your body. We
went through that thoroughly. So, now,
how does that prove the resurrection?
Look at Jesus's brilliance. Well, since
God created humans to be composite
beings composed of matter and soul and
spirit, for God to still be the God of
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob after they
physically died means they haven't
ceased to be because he's not the God of
non-living things. But at the same time,
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob are meant to
be more than spirits. They were created
to be embodied spirits, embodied souls
with a physical body, which means that
God will eventually raise their bodies
because he won't leave them a shell of
their former selves. That's how he
proved the resurrection.
Yeah. And we're not Gnostics. Like, it's
not like, oh, the physical is bad and
oh, the spiritual is good and we'll just
be this we won't have a glorified body
forever. because that's sort of the uh
one of the straw men I commonly hear
from them when you argue against this
is, oh well you so you don't think we're
going to there's going to be a physical
resurrection.
Well, no, of course we do. But the point
is is that in between now and then you
don't have a sessation of of existence
and this is just another proof of that.
Yeah. And to confirm death doesn't mean
what they think it means. If someone
like asked me how can eternal life the
soul dies because you're not listening
heretic
death does not mean ceizing to exist
just like we saw in last week's section
Ephesians 2 3-7 it says we were dead in
sins and made alive in Christ do any of
you think that when I was dead in sin
before I became a believer I was no
longer consciously
alive or existing Colossians 113 stop
your nonsense guys you're butchering
scripture but go ahead
How many more clips you got on this?
A couple more.
All right,
we're going to get into uh 1
Thessalonians 4:13-14.
Now,
you're kidding.
Now, let's continue to read in 1
Thessalonians chapter 4. Let's start
from verse 13.
It says, "But I would not have you to be
ignorant, brethren, concerning them
which are asleep, that these sorrow not,
even as others which have no hope. For
if we believe that Jesus died and rose
again, even so them which sleep in Jesus
will God bring with him."
Bam. Easily refuted again, Sam. 1
Thessalonians 4 says, "Those who sleep
in Jesus will come with him at his
second coming." So that proves man has
no immaterial conscious aspect to his
being. They refuted you, right?
Yeah. Now, brother, you see how they
ended up having Paul contradict John?
Didn't they tell you? Now, guys,
understand why these guys are Sorry,
guys. You are clowns. May you repent.
The Lord expose you. And I hope he uses
this. Do you guys remember they quoted
John 14 that says Jesus will come to
them and take them to where he is? But
now they're saying Jesus is going to
bring them with him when he returns. So
which is it?
Yeah. See, because they're only
recognizing both as the as a singular
event, not two distinct events.
But brother, right here, 1 Thessalonians
4:14, it says, "For we believe that
Jesus died and rose again, even so them
also which sleep in will God bring with
him." What is he bringing back when they
just told us John 14 he's coming to take
them
to be where he is? But it says no,
they're coming with him.
Did you catch it?
Yeah. I mean it it just it it makes you
makes me wonder if like they remember
what they say previously or if like
everything is just viewed vacuously
because I don't understand how you you
seriously can't remember what you just
said like seven minutes ago.
Right. And secondly, this actually
proves our point. Something is coming
with Jesus and something is coming out
of the grave and awakening.
Yeah.
Because it says those who sleep. Why is
death called sleep? Because it's talking
about the position of the body.
Yeah.
When you see the body, the body is prone
as if it's asleep. But the metaphor
asleep means just like you sleep, you'll
awaken. the body will awaken when when
he brings them with him to enter their
bodies that then awaken out of the
grave. That actually makes our case. The
body awakens from the grave and the
souls are coming with him to enter those
bodies that are now glorified.
And to prove to you that Paul
distinguishes the body from the soul
spirit, it's ironic they quote 1
Thessalonians
right here chapter 4. Can you read 1
Thessalonians 5:23?
Same book, right?
Yep.
These guys are very bad, brother. They
thought they refuting us.
Now, may the God of peace himself
sanctify you completely, and may your
whole spirit and soul and body be kept
blameless at the coming of our Lord
Jesus Christ. This makes absolutely no
sense if we go with their definition
because if soul cannot refer to a
distinct aspect from your body or that
spirit cannot refer distinct aspect from
your body then Paul is making no sense.
Why say that God preserve you wholly
completely not just your body but your
soul and spirit. But in light of what
Paul said now, 1 Thessalonians 4:14
makes sense because what's coming with
them would be the soul and spirit.
What's awakening is their body. Thank
you guys for proving our case.
They just proved their case, brothers.
And there's just more begging of the
question and simply assuming their view
of the nature of man without proving it.
If you remember the very first clip of
yours that they listened to, which
they've only listened to two so far, the
very first clip that they listened to,
they just assumed their own view of
death and they missed the argument you
were making. You were saying it's
problematic for their position if Jesus
was, you know, if soul sleep is correct,
why this was problematic. They didn't
actually address that. They just went on
to argue, well, Jesus really died.
Okay.
Well, right. And we agree. the way
you're defining that is the problem. And
that's the whole point and the objection
you were raising. Well, here we are
40ome minutes into their video and they
still have not proven that. They've just
uh essentially assumed that.
Yeah, boy.
Let's continue.
God brought anyone to his kingdom that
has died yet. Besides the exception that
we just spoke about,
the Bible says in verse 14, even so them
which sleep in Jesus will God bring with
him.
Let's continue to read. For this we say
unto you by the word of the Lord, that
ye that we which are alive and remain
unto the coming of the Lord shall not
prevent them which are asleep. For the
Lord himself shall descend from heaven
with a shout, with the voice of the
archangel, and with the trump of God.
And the dead in Christ shall rise first.
Then we which are alive and remain shall
be caught up together with them in the
clouds and meet the Lord in the air. And
so shall we ever be with the Lord. The
Bible says that the dead know nothing
and they will be resurrected at the
second coming of Jesus to meet him in
the air and be with him in the kingdom
forever. get up.
Amen. Amen. Um, I wanted to just answer
this real quick. Uh, Bro Cliff, Brother
Cliff, Jesus didn't run the universe as
a man. What? That's horrible. I'm not
saying that, Brother Cliff. So, don't
misquote me. I'm not saying Jesus did
not run the universe as a man. What I'm
saying is he had a divine nature and he
had a human nature. And the Bible tells
us that he truly did die. Um, but as far
as his divine nature, the Bible tells us
God is immortal. So that divine nature
that Jesus has, um, I don't believe that
it's possible for divinity to die if it
says he's immortal, but yet it says he
truly did die. And so what I'm leaving
this to is mystery. I'm saying I don't
know how this is possible, but the Bible
says he is God and the Bible says he
truly did die. And I'm saying this is a
mysterious thing, you know, because he
says I have power to raise myself up.
The Bible also makes it clear that God
runs the universe. Jesus is God, you
know, he is one of the three persons of
the Godhead. And so, is he running the
universe as a man? Again, I cannot
answer that. So, one thing is, don't
misquote me. I'm not saying that he
didn't run the universe. I'm not saying
that at all.
What, bro? What are you talking about,
man?
And so during that time when he was on
earth, we understand that the father and
the holy spirit, they were really
running the universe. They were really
running the universe.
We understand that Jesus growing up had
to learn things. Correct?
So we understand that at at certain
points that you know Jesus was not
running the universe. Jesus was not
running the universe.
He yielded that um he yielded I guess
the keys or the rights to the entire
cosmos to his father.
Does that make sense?
Mhm.
Amen. Amen.
Amen.
[Music]
God runs the universe. But as far as how
the father, son, and holy spirit are
interacting on what does what or who
does what in the universe,
that's them. You know, I think if you
know the answer, you can tell me. But
I'm saying we're going to have to find
out when God tells us or when the
father, son, and holy ghost tell us. But
um yeah, what I am saying is that God
runs the universe. How did that happen
when Jesus was dead? the father
mysterious to me. I believe the father
did take over. I believe the holy spirit
did take over. But when Jesus was dead,
it's it's what what role does he have in
operating the universe when he's dead.
That's a that's a mystery to me. I'm not
saying he did. He didn't. It's just a
mystery. But I Bible does confirm that
he truly did die. So that's what I'm
saying. Please do not
the fact that he had to humble himself
as a man and rely on father for strength
and all these things. I don't think it's
a far stretch that especially in the
running of the universe which is
probably a big task that the father and
the holy spirit could have took up the
reigns until he came back.
But of course it would always be a
mystery because we weren't there to be
honest. But I mean I think a an
understanding could be made that if they
wanted the father and the spirit could
have definitely took over in his place
especially when he humbled himself to
being to be as a man and he could not be
an effective man or human being had he
not fully take on the um what's the
right word the nature of man as far as
the the fatigue and all these things
that we as human beings go through. So,
I believe especially as Jay said it
earlier before and Deontay made
reference to as well, um the father and
and the spirit of God is more than
capable of taking over while he finishes
his ministry on earth on behalf of men.
Wow. It is like these guys don't even
remember what they say 10 minutes after
saying it. Yet, they all three claimed
that. And these guys are supposed to be
part of the restoration of apostolic
Christianity. But this really sums up
perfectly why Answering Adventism does
not take these guys seriously or really
engage with them. It would just lower my
credibility and people would say,
"You're going for lowhanging fruit,
people that actually know their stuff."
That's what they would say. Their entire
defense was that the Father and the Holy
Spirit held down the fort while Jesus
was dead, which Randy, the guy at the
bottom, just stated there at the end yet
again after they claimed that isn't what
they were saying. He said, 'The Father
and the Holy Spirit took over the reigns
until Jesus came back. Slipping in the
word mystery doesn't now get you off the
hook. Welcome to Adventist
Christologology, ladies and gentlemen.
They can tell you all about the pope
being the antichrist and what every
symbol in the Bible allegedly
represents, but they can't figure out if
Jesus was running the universe while his
physical body lay in the tomb. And then,
did you even did you catch it? They even
slid out a comment from an Adventist
that said the exact same thing. Remember
that the father was the comment said,
"Remember that the father was running
the universe while Jesus was dead." The
comment said, "Don't forget the father
runs the universe even if his son died
on the cross." Amen. That's what the
comet said. Totally heretical nonsense.
Yes, the hypothatic union is a mystery.
Yes, aspects of God are mysterious. No
disagreements there. But this is not one
of those cases. Jason said, "Well, when
God tells us, well, Jason, God has
already told us and it's in his word and
we just showed you this in the last part
and Sam is probably going to show you
more here. Um, this isn't you can just
appeal to some, well, we just don't
know. Scriptur is not clear on this. Um,
or it's just too mysterious for us to
actually be able to know." No, this
horrible theology creates division
within the triune God. And it evidences
once again, Adventists are not taught to
believe and worship the true God.
They're taught to use certain words.
He's using a bunch of Christian Ees
here. He's saying Godhead and three
persons and but when you practically
look at how this is applied and how
they're handling the Bible, I'm telling
you folks, I'm going to keep saying
this. I don't care. There's former
Adventists, for example, they'll tell
me, "Well, I I knew the true Jesus as an
Adventist, and praise God if you did,
but organizationally and for the most
part, I'm going to continue saying this.
They are not taught actual Christian
trinitarian theology. They do not know
the true God and they have a false god.
And what these guys are putting forth
here is not the true God. It's a
different Jesus. Second Corinthians 11
1-4. It's a false Christ. Paul warned,
don't follow after other spirits, other
Christs, etc. That's what we have going
on here. And this is also why I tell
former Adventists, you must must must
must study fundamental Christian
christologology because if you don't,
you will end up making the sort of
blunders that these guys are making.
Sam, your thoughts.
Yeah. Now, beautiful you did it because
I thought I was going to show how he
contradicts himself. But you did a
masterful job. Glory to Jesus Christ.
You took the clips showing how he did
deny Jesus was running the universe.
then later says don't you know claim I
said he did or he didn't it's a mystery
but then in the same conversation the
guy in the bottom then reiterates what
he earlier did say and what Deante said
no Jesus was not running the universe
the father and spirit were. So they're
contradicting themselves left and right
and embarrassing themselves and you
hammered the point perfectly. Now if you
go to part one they quoted 1 Timothy
3:16 to show that great is the mystery
of godliness that God was manifest in
the flesh saying see it's a mystery but
if you go back to the session and watch
the lexican doesn't define mystery the
way they do the word mysterion means
something hidden that was secret and now
revealed. So, they're even
misappropriating the term mystery in 1
Timothy 3:16, but they're all over the
map. Now, that remind me something
before I move on. Earlier, one of them
said, "Jesus taught us to pray to the
father." Do they not pray to Jesus?
They will.
Okay? Because that because I then I
don't need to address it because they
said, "See, Jesus taught us to pray to
the father in the context of Jesus
somehow truly dying, ceasing to exist,
and not running the universe." And I
kind of baffled me. Yeah. But he didn't
say pray to the father no one. So that
point we can leave. So that at least
they don't deny that you pray to Jesus.
Okay, that's fine. So you you butchered
them. There was nothing for me to add.
You just annihilated them. Show they're
contradicting themselves left and right.
Well, it's going to get worse now.
Watch.
Right. And Jamie is saying it perfectly.
I am not denying that Jesus was God when
he was a man. Jesus is always God.
The father is always God. The son is
always God. The Holy Spirit is always
God. how they decide to do their work,
that's on them. You know, I just only
speak with what the Bible tells me. If
you want to tell me the verses that tell
me that Jesus was operating, and I'll
take those verses and I'll just preach
the verses. Um, yeah. And then he says,
uh, that's why that's horrible because
it's obvious he ran the universe as a
man. Okay, Brother Cliff, if you want to
if you want to take that, I'm not going
to argue with you about that if that's
what you want to say. But all I'm saying
is don't misquote me. I'm not saying he
did run the universe as a man. I'm not
saying he didn't. I'm saying it's a
mystery for me. But if if you're clear
on it, then go with it. Um maybe others
are clear on it, too.
So Sam, I know there wasn't much
substance there, but I wanted to play
that for Christians to further see.
Adventism is not trinitarian.
And I'm going to reiterate this again. I
get a lot of flack from people,
including some Christians and lots of
former Adventists, for saying this. But
I have zero plans of stopping. Just add
this to the long list of examples. So,
they aren't saying that Jesus wasn't God
as a man or that he didn't run the
universe while on earth, even though
they all three outright said that Jesus
left that to the father and the Holy
Spirit. And Daniel 7 proves the glory
Jesus received was the keys to the
universe being given back to him. Even
though, like we saw in part one, their
organizational source documents use
Philippians 2 the exact same way these
guys did, which says he set his divine
nature aside, as well as that he took
upon himself in angel nature, becoming
Michael the Archangel, if you remember
those sources, signs of the times.
Welcome to the mess that is Adventist
Christologology, ladies and gentlemen, a
doctrinal fork in the road that leads
you either after the true Christ or a
false Christ.
But they know going to church on Sunday
will be the mark of the beast after a
three-fold union between Roman
Catholicism, Protestants, and
spiritualism. That's crystal clear in
the Bible. And they'll stake their flag
on that. But whether or not Jesus was
running the universe while on earth,
nope. Bible's not clear.
Bible's not clear. Anything you want to
add to that, Sam? before now they move
into the final two here and you're going
to get your answer to something you got
a little bit ahead of uh in part one
which is them defining what is the
difference between spirit and what is
the difference between soul
yeah just want to remind you watch part
one because I showed the scripture says
that Christ has never stopped Hebrews 1
8-12 it's in part one you got to go back
Hebrews 1 8-12 Christ has never stopped
even when he became flesh incarnate
never stopped preserving alive,
sustaining the heavens and the earth.
That's Hebrews 1:8-12. Where the father
glorifies Jesus as Yahweh at the
beginning laid the foundation of the
earth and made the heavens by his hands,
meaning his infinite power. He rolls
them up. He changes them. But it says
you are the same. Your years never end.
He has never stopped even incarnate one
with the father and the spirit. He was
still preserving creation in his own
body and raised his body with the father
in the spirit. It's there. Hebrews 1
8:12. Lord willing. I guess these are
two final clips, huh?
Yep. So, now we're going to hear what is
a spirit? And you're going to hear some
familiar verses in here, Sam, that
you've already referenced. See if you
can notice the difference in usage.
Uh, you know, the other thing I wanted
to talk about real quick is he was
talking about disembodied spirits and
and souls. Like, I just want to real
quick like what is a spirit anyway? I
think we should also have a clear
definition of what we're talking about
when we say spirit and when we say soul.
Randy, can you help me out real quick?
Yeah, I think I think spirit can mean a
few things. Um, if you go to Matthew
chapter 14 26, we can see a definition.
Matthew 14
verse 26.
Matthew 14:26.
Okay.
Yes. And so this is obviously when back
start verse 25 and I look at the context
for verse 26
Matthew 14:25. It says, "And in the
fourth watch of the night, Jesus went
unto them walking on the sea. And when
the disciples saw him walking on the
sea, they were troubled, saying, it is a
spirit, and they cried out for fear."
Now, go into the original um language,
Jay, for that. And I think there's a
word that really kind of embodies what
the disciples were experiencing, right?
Fantasma.
Fantasma. But now look what it says. um
uh spectra spirit h when we look at it,
if we're looking at somebody or spirit
with fear, then nine times 10, we're
probably thinking it is a ghost. And in
fact, if you go to other versions, I'm
not I don't know if you do this, but you
know, especially, you know, the other
versions like uh I don't know, ESV or
ASV, those type of um breakdowns. I'm
not sure if it's in the KJV, though. Oh,
there is actually. I didn't even know.
So, there you go. It is a ghost.
All right. So that's one. All right. So
a spirit in this context as far as
Matthew 14:26 especially with the fear
that they had, you know, they were
spooked by it. So they thought it was a
ghost. If you go to James chapter 26,
you can see another definition of what
possibly a spirit may mean as well. All
right. So last verse is for as a body
without the spirit is dead. So faith
without works is dead. Now there's
another a more better understanding of
what the spirit is in that. Is there is
there a original meaning for this one as
well? Okay.
Yep. It says uh for the body without the
spirit G4151.
And so it's the word numa
and it can mean a current of air that is
breath.
It can also mean a rational soul, a
spirit, vital principle, mental
disposition.
Yep.
Yeah.
So if we look at the context
clearly um in understanding um if we
look at Genesis chapter 2 verse 7,
right? When we understand that the
when we look at the beginning where it
says the body plus the breath or okay,
we're going to go there. Why not? Uh
Genesis 2:7 and God formed man of the
dust of the earth. of the ground and
breathed in his nostrils the what? The
the breath of life.
Breath of life. All right. And what man
became a
living soul.
So human beings did not become alive
until it was the body plus the breath of
life. And so when we look
at the connection between what James is
making now go back to James chapter 2
verse 26. Now look at the connection as
well. Sorry. Go back to James 2:26.
Now let's look at the same connection
right it says for as the body without
the spirit. Now we can look at that we
we saw the original meaning also means
breath. I think spirit the word the word
breath would be the the best contextual
um interpretation for the word spirit in
this in this passage. Right? So it says
for as a body without the breath of life
we could say is dead so faith without
works is dead. Does that is that clear?
go to the original language, he says,
whips out the concordance.
But more hopscotching all over the Bible
with a concordance, not even walking
through the text to see how the words
are being used in context. But Sam, like
I said, I got ahead of myself back in
part one when you asked if they
differentiate between spirit and soul
and their appeal to Genesis. Here you
heard the spirit is breath claim. Yeah,
we also brought up James 2 in part one
and you demonstrated why this verse is
problematic for their position. Their
claim being that James is saying that
the body without the breath is dead like
faith without works is dead. And Genesis
2:7 is also supposed to support this.
They're going to circle back around to
Genesis 2:7 in a moment. So, let's
discuss that then. But for those that
may have missed it in part one, why is
their interpretation of James 2:26
flawed for their position?
Now, I want you to see how they just
completely destroyed and annihilated
themselves. Pun intended. Didn't they
quote to Ezekiel 18:4 that says the soul
that sin shall die?
They did.
But now they're telling you that here
the soul doesn't die because the body
dies when the soul leaves, which is the
breath. So, does the soul die or doesn't
die? Well, they're saying here that the
spirit is breath. They're going to get
into what the soul is.
That's why I said that because living
soul, Genesis 2:7. That's No, because
they said here it's the breath of life.
Living soul.
Yeah.
But here we're going with their
definition even though it's not.
Here we're going to take it as soul
because they quoted Genesis 2:7, living
soul. Yeah.
Link to this.
Okay, let's go with it. Now you guys
just annihilate yourselves because you
said the soul that sin shall die, so the
soul dies. But you just quoted James
2:26 and according to James 2:26,
the body dies when the spirit leaves and
that spirit is the breath of life. Well,
it's that breath of life that makes you
a living soul. So now you're saying the
soul doesn't die. It's the body and the
body dies because the soul leaves. Make
up your mind. Does the soul die and
ceases to be? Or is it the body that
dies, but the soul, which is the breath
of life infused,
doesn't die, but leaves the body. You
can't have your cake and eat it too. So
what do they believe? Does the soul die
or the soul is the breath that leaves
your body and it's your body that dies?
Because at first they're saying the soul
dies. You see how they just annihilated
well and not just that, but again it
needs to be pointed out because you're
going to get Adventists that miss what
you're saying here. If you're going to
appeal to Genesis 2:7 and say it has a
connection or make some sort of
connection to what's being said in James
2, then you have to you can't do this
sort of dichotomy between soul and
spirit like they're going to do here
momentarily. Um if they wanted to be
consistent.
Yep.
That's the point. If they're trying to
be if if they want to be consistent,
that's the point.
That's my point. Now, secondly, even the
lexican he cited says that this word
puma can mean rational spirit.
Yeah, I know they didn't even catch
that. No, he said rational soul.
Yep. Even Yeah. And I I read rational,
but you may be right. Rational spirit.
Okay. That means it's not just breath.
It's referring to meaning a soul that is
aware and alert or a spirit that is. But
now they went conveniently for the
definition breath. Why? Prove it
contextually. Thirdly, they read Matthew
14:26 and for the life of me, I do not
understand how they could not see that
destroyed their position. Because the
apostles thought they saw a fantasm, a
ghost. Well, if the apostles worldview
did not allow for spirits to exist apart
from the body so that spirits could
appear as fantasms,
why would they think they're seeing a
fantasm if they believe that when you
die that's it? It's over with.
Do you see how that just
Yeah. What?
Go ahead. I was just going to say I I
it's funny because I cite that often to
Adventists to show them why their
position is wrong and here they are
citing it thinking it somehow helps
their position. That's exactly it. If
the apostles had the same belief that
these guys do that the Adventist church
does. Well, what Jesus said there
doesn't align with your position.
Yep. And that also found in Luke 24:36
to 43. When Jesus appeared, they thought
they were seeing a spirit. But then
Jesus, touch my hand.
Spirits do not.
Yeah. Spirits who don't have flesh and
bones as you see I have.
Okay. Once again I want to ask this goes
back with Acts 23 6-9 where Paul says I
am a Pharisee and I believe like the
Pharisees there are spirits and angels
that exist. If the apostles world view
Paul's worldview was that my soul dies
my spirit dies because
I am my soul I am my spirit and death
means I cease to exist. Then my question
is, how come the apostles believed that
they could see spirits appear to them?
And which spirits did appear to them
like Moses and Elijah and like Onas and
Jeremiah and Samuel? If they had the
same understanding of soul, spirit, and
death that these guys do.
Yeah. It doesn't work.
Thank you.
Now, they talk about between what we
just listened to and them talking about
the soul, they appeal to 1 Corinthians
2:10 as well as 1 John 4:1.
Terrible
to both to both basically say that that
proves that soul sleep is essentially
true and that death is what they claim
death is, etc.
Now, we can look at those if you want,
or we can just move ahead to this final
clip because if I'm being completely
honest with you, I am so sick of
listening to these Bible perverts.
Yes. Let me just make one comment. 1
Corinthians 2, how can they say that is
the soul? Because it's contrasting the
spirit in man with the spirit of God. So
they're saying the spirit of God is
God's soul. They say 1 Corinthians 2:10
is supposed to prove soul sleep
apparently because it uses the word
spirit to refer to the mind of a person.
Therefore, they refuted you.
The mind of a person.
Well, we can listen to it. It's not a
super long
I know. I'm just saying I agree what
you're saying, but I'm saying look at
what they just did there. It's talking
about the spirit in man as an analogy to
the spirit of God. Just like the spirit
within man knows what a man is thinking,
so to the spirit of God knows the deep
things of God. So if they're going to be
consistent, it's the same Greek word.
Are they saying now that the spirit
there, which is supposedly the mind, the
soul, it means that the Holy Spirit is
God's soul and mind and not a distinct
person. So they're no longer
Trinitarians.
Yeah. Well, they don't get into that
aspect of the of the text, but they're
basically just trying to show that again
they bring up their concordance and
they're like, look, it has a semantic
range and in this case the context best
best uh you know yields us saying that
it's talking about the mind of a person
and so
yeah, let me correct them. It talks
about we have the mind of Christ doesn't
say it but says we have the mind of
Christ. So they think now my mind is
Christ's mind. We have the same mind.
Yeah. Again, I I think they look at
things very very vacuously,
but uh
let's go to final clip. Yeah. Terrible.
Yeah. Let So the the final one, what is
a soul? I got to hop ahead here a little
bit. Like I said,
terrible. Terrible.
I got to get to it as close as I can.
Are you kidding me? Not this. Are you
kidding me?
Okay.
Um
A living soul, living being. And I'll
stop right there.
Amen.
Yeah. And um I wanted to just also just
for the record so that we have what does
a soul mean? Of course, Genesis chapter
2:7. This is the first time we really
see the word. And well, actually it's
not the really first time. You can see
it in Genesis 1 also. Every creature
that had life, right? That's really
where we see the first time we see that
word. But and the Lord God formed man of
the dust of the ground and breathed into
his nostrils the breath of life and man
became a living soul. So we see the
first time that the word soul is being
used is when God is forming men and
putting his breath of life in them and
they become a living soul. So we can see
that the word soul and I'll just look it
up. Um the word soul in the concordance
H5315
that is the word nephesh and we
understand that in the Bible it means
soul 416 times particularly in the old
testament and it means life 100 times
and it also mean the person. Uh, one
example that we can see this in is um,
what is it? 1 Corinthians, sorry, sorry,
first Kings chapter
17 verse 21, right? Where there was a
boy that was dead and Elijah was
praying. It says, "And he stretched
himself upon the child three times and
cried unto the Lord and said, Oh Lord,
my God, I pray thee, let this child's
soul come into him again."
Yeah.
So this is another definition of the
word soul, which means life, right? And
the Lord heard the voice of Elijah and
the soul of the child came into him
again and he revived or the life of the
person. And if we understand that the
dead know nothing only God has
immortality. The soul that sins it shall
die. We understand that this soul could
not have been flying around or in some
place because he would be immortal if
that was the case.
So when we understand that we see the
word soul, we have to mean life, you
know, because the word soul can mean um
life. Let me let me just
Can you emphasize that? Can you can you
emphasize that again, brother? What you
just said?
If I got what I just said, if sessation
of life happened in regards to the
physical body and continue flying
around, then technically he would be
immortal.
Yeah. Yeah. He would be immortal.
And and so I'm not sure if you guys get
the verse yet, but you guys I hope you
guys at least in the audience, you kind
of see where we're going. He did give
the verse actually um in 1 Timothy 6. So
God alone has immortality. So, so you're
indirectly saying that even if the
physical body dies, but a spirit form
lives on, which means you never really
die because your consciousness never
stopped. What you're in turn calling the
person is immortal.
Wow, these guys are jokes. So, their
butchering of Ecclesiastes 9:3 was
buried, like I said, back in part one
where we saw how their proof text method
of interpretation causes them to take
Solomon's words from the vantage point
of wic of a wicked person and then
applies them as a science lesson from
God. But still operating on that errant
assumption, Sam, first Kings 17 proves
that man has no immaterial conscious
aspect to his being. Because if we did,
that would mean every human being has
natural immortality, which only God has.
Therefore, Christians are wrong.
Yeah, you guys are jokes. I pray you
repent and the Lord shuts you down
because you guys are worse than Muslims.
I'll be honest. Number one, notice the
contradiction again. The child died
because the soul left, right? But then
the child live because the soul came
back. That's what they quote in First
Kings 17, right?
Because it just means life. It doesn't
mean there's any sort of conscious.
Okay, but let's go with it. But in
Ezekiel 18:4, it says, "The soul that
sin shall die." So what is leaving? The
soul itself dies.
So what it's leaving? What's leaving?
The life.
So but it says in Ezekiel 18:4, the soul
dies, so the life dies. So the life, how
are they defining soul to be the life
that lives that leaves? But then they're
telling me it's a soul that dies. So if
the soul dies, what do you mean it's
leaving? It doesn't leave, it dies. It
ceases to be.
So yeah, understand what I'm trying to
get at here.
At one place they want to say the soul
dies, meaning sees exist. But another
place they're saying, see, he died
because the soul left. Well, if the soul
leaves, that means it's the body that's
dying, not the soul in this context.
Which goes back to the point I'm making
that the term soul can a broad range of
meaning, not one meaning. Because if I
were to nail them on their etmological
fallacy, no, nothing leaves. The soul
dies. That's it. Nothing leaves. Because
when the soul dies, it ceases to be
nothing leaves. Now I'm getting to see
that words can have different meanings
depending on their use and context.
That's number one. So now they at least
acknowledge physical death occurs when
the soul leaves or the spirit leaves.
Now let me show you where the soul can
leave the body die and the soul still be
conscious. We looked at it last week.
Revelation 69-11.
So let's now show them they don't know
how to interpret scripture. And then
about immortality, they again show they
don't understand scripture because the
same Paul says that God who alone is
immortal by nature has conferred
immortality as grace to those who
believe. See these guys don't know the
Bible. They're even worse than than
Muslims. So in Revelation 6911, remember
the soul is the life, the breath. It's
not
rational according to them. Even though
one of the definitions is that it's a
rational soul. And so when you die, your
soul dies. Even though now they're going
to say, "No, when you die, it's because
your soul leaves." But then when your
soul leaves, it's basically nothing
because you don't continue to exist as a
soul. All right. Revelation 69 to 111.
When it does it real quick, and it just
it doesn't make any sense, and it's just
so full of contradictions because
they're saying the soul is a result.
Remember the boards and nails. The soul
is a result of those two things being
together. The spirit being the breath
and the body come together to make the
soul. When the spirit departs from the
body, the soul ceases to exist entirely.
And this is the problem, folks, with
this hopscotching around. And again, it
kind of circles us back as well to
Matthew 10 and Jesus's own dichotomy
between the body and and the soul.
But when he opened the fifth seal, I saw
under the altar the souls of those who
had been slain for the word of God and
for the witness they had borne. They
cried out with a loud voice, "Oh
sovereign Lord, holy and true, how long
before you will judge and avenge our
blood on those who dwell on the earth."
Then they were each given a white robe
and told to rest a little longer until
the number of their fellow servants and
their brothers should be complete who
were to be killed as they themselves had
been. Now, I mentioned this last week.
I'm going to repeat it again. Number
one, they're not going to die. There's
an actual altar in heaven.
Number two, they're not going to deny
that Jesus though he's not in the as you
were telling me in the most holy place
that he's in heaven, right? They're not
going to deny that.
Well, he is now. He But he wasn't in
there until 1844.
Oh, excellent. Where was he then if it
wasn't in heaven?
He was in the first apartment doing an
analogous work to the Levitical
priesthood.
And where is that?
Uh, it's in a heavenly tabernacle
building that was just like what's on
earth, but what was on earth was a scale
model. though he only entered into that
outer holy place apartment until 1844.
Well, that makes my case cuz the altar
would be there too, right? I
if it if they were being consistent.
Yes. Because they claim again it's an
identical they say Hebrews 8
specifically verse 5 tells us that what
was on earth is identical to what is in
heaven. So that would include there
would have to be an altar.
Okay. So they're going to take Jesus is
in the heavenly tabernacle, the first
compartment, the holy place. Well, the
altar is there. So that's actual. Jesus
is actually there. And yet these souls
are not actually there. This is how they
want to interpret the text. So notice
how they're going to interpret the text.
There aren't actual souls before the
altar, but there is an actual altar.
Jesus is actually there because this is
the first compartment of the heavenly
tabernacle. So those parts we take as
actual. But the souls who are speaking
or aware that they were murdered and
want to be avenged, that's not actual
because they're Bible perverts. And the
part where Jesus says that he'll avenge
them, which he'll actually do until the
full number of their brothers will be
killed, that's actual. But the souls who
are crying is not actual. You see what
they do? So right there, here's in a
case where souls are conscious, they're
alive, they're feeling angry because of
what happened to them, and they want to
be avenged. So, so much for narrowing
narrowing the definition of soul to one
meaning. Well, let's see. Spirits. Go to
Hebrews 12:22-24.
Yep. Which we also looked at this.
Yeah. We're going to have great detail.
Yep. Hebrews 12:22-24.
Oh,
but you have come to Mount Zion. So,
he's making a compare and contrast here
between um Si and Mount Zion. You have
come to Mount Zion, the city of the
living God, the heavenly Jerusalem, and
to the innumerable angels in festal
gathering, and to the assembly of the
firstborn, who are enrolled in heaven,
and to God the judge of all, and to the
spirits of the righteous made perfect,
and to Jesus, the mediator of a new
covenant, and to the sprinkled blood
that speaks a better word than the blood
of Abel.
Now, let's break this down. They
acknowledge there are angels in heaven.
They acknowledge there's an actual
heavenly Jerusalem. I assume, right?
Yep.
They acknowledge that Jesus is there and
that he's he will if he hasn't present
his blood. But it also says there are
spirits of just men made perfect. And
notice what's missing their bodies
because their bodies were killed, but
they're there in spirits. We know this
can't be referring to Jesus's coming to
the earth because when he comes to the
earth, they won't be merely spirits.
There'll be whole persons with bodies,
but they're not there with bodies. So,
it cannot refer to as coming to the
earth. It's in heaven, heavenly
Jerusalem. So, now here two passages
where in one place they're said to be
spirits there in heaven. Another place
said to be souls.
Then when we add Matthew 10:28, do not
fear the one who can kill the body but
not kill the soul. Rather, fear the one
who can destroy both body and soul and
hell. Gehina there again there are
places which soul is not identical to
your body your soul is distinguished
from your body as your spirit is and in
these places soul and spirit continue to
consciously exist just like angels
consciously exist in heaven and the
father's consciously existing in heaven
with Jesus but now about immortality
which they keep butchering 1 Timothy 6
14- 16 let's now deal with that because
again That shows you they do not know
how to interpret scripture.
Yeah, Adventists love this verse. They
think it's just what you the Christians
believe means everyone has immortality
then. So this says only God has
immortality. So therefore,
yeah, they don't
they don't know how to interpret
scripture. Man, it's sad. But hopefully
they'll repent. If they're honest,
they're going to leave this cult. Let's
see if you're honest. Now watch what
they keep doing this passage. Now I'm
show you again. They don't know
scripture. Why? Because if they take
this the way they do, it said Jesus is
also the only potentate, the only
sovereign ruler. But hold on,
if we take this literally, that means
there are no other potentates and rulers
that exist. But we know that when Paul
wrote this, there were Roman potentates,
right?
Yep.
But if we take the way they're defining
it, no, it cannot be. 1 Timothy 6:14-16.
Watch here.
to keep the commandment unstained and
free from reproach until the appearing
of our Lord Jesus Christ, which he will
display at the proper time. He who is
blessed and the only sovereign, the King
of Kings and Lord of Lords, who alone
has immortality, who dwells in
unapproachable light, whom no one ever
uh has ever seen or can see. To him be
honor and eternal dominion. Amen. Now if
we take their interpretation if he's the
only sovereign meaning pontentate there
are no other sovereigns. When Paul wrote
this there were hundreds of sovereigns.
Caesar was a sovereign pontentate on
earth. Well what's the meaning? The
meaning isn't there aren't other
sovereigns because even the next line
king of kings and lord of lords. Last
time I checked if you're lord you're
king. That means you have sovereignty
right?
Yeah. And not just that but if he's king
of kings then there's other kings.
That's my point. If you're a king and a
lord, that means you have sovereignty,
right?
Correct.
But how can he be king of kings, lord of
lords, without these kings and lords
also having sovereignty,
right? Or they wouldn't be kings.
But if they have sovereignty, then that
mean Jesus ain't the only sovereign
according to their logic.
They're geniuses, huh?
Okay. So, what does it mean? Let's now
break down.
[Music]
Let me break down what it means. When it
says Christ is the only sovereign, the
meaning is simple. Like you find in
Daniel 2:37-38.
You don't need to turn there. Daniel
4:24-26.
Daniel 4:31-37.
It means God
who is supreme and has all power must
allow someone to rule otherwise no one
can rule. Only sovereign means he is the
true source of all power and authority
and rulership. But that God has allowed
creatures to share in his sovereignty
under his headship. Similarly, when it
says alone has immortality, it means God
alone is immortal by nature. Everyone
else is immortal by grace. So if they
interpret this the way they do, then
when Jesus says those who believe in him
shall never die, never ever,
that means this contradicts Paul.
Because if you never die, that means
you're immortal. But now let's go to
second Timothy 1 7 to12 because that
shows they do not know how to interpret
scripture. They interpret scripture like
Muslims do as well as Unitarians. 2
Timothy 1:7-12. And in verse 10, it
tells you Jesus came to usher in
immortality. Why? Hey, Paul. Whoa. No,
no, no, no. He alone is immortal. He
can't make anyone else immortal.
For God gave us a spirit not of fear,
but of power and love and self-control.
Therefore, do not be ashamed of the
testimony about our Lord, nor of me, his
prisoner, but share in suffering for the
gospel by the power of God, who saved us
and called us to a holy calling, not
because of our works, but because of his
own purpose and grace, which he gave us
in Christ uh Jesus before the ages
began, and which now has been manifested
through the appearing of our savior,
Christ Jesus, who abolished death and
brought life and immortality to light
through the gospel
for which I was appointed a preacher and
apostle and teacher which is why I
suffer as I do but I am not ashamed for
I know whom I have believed and I am
convinced that he is able to guard until
that day what has been entrusted to me.
So Paul says that the gospel makes known
the life and immortality that Jesus has
brought not just to himself that's not
the good news to those who believe. But
hold on, Paul. Didn't you just say that
Christ alone is immortal?
Yeah. How can then Jesus bring life to
us and immortality to us through the
revelation of the gospel? If we believe
if he alone is immortal. No, you can't
do that, Paul. Even if you say it's
future mortality, alone means alone. If
he alone is immortal, that means at no
stage can you ever be immortal if these
guys were consistent,
right? Because they're saying, "Oh, if
you don't die, that means you're
immortal." Well, hold on. Do you not
believe a time will come where you will
be immortal? Well, if alone means he
alone is immortal, that means at no
point in your existence could you ever
be immortal because that means he isn't
the only one who's immortal.
Correct.
There you go for their ex Jesus.
Sam, thank you for going through the
torture of this with me.
Wasn't torture, but Jesus is worthy and
I it is an honor for me to serve you for
the glory of Christ.
I appreciate it, gentlemen. Uh the silly
antics are not going to work. The only
reason that we did this was because
again, they wanted to insert themselves
into a situation that they thought they
were putting their cape on and saving a
victim, etc. Except, yeah, the guy
reached out of his own valition and I
was just trying to be nice and let him
come on, but okay. So instead, we just
buried their teaching and demonstrated
for people, this is why this platform
does not take these guys seriously. We
will not be doing this regularly because
again, there are smart Seventh Day
Adventists out there, folks. But getting
them to engage is like pulling teeth. So
that's why I have to engage with the
sermons, with the the articles that
they've written, the website, the books,
etc., because that's where they're
putting their stuff out there, and I
have to have a sort of one-sided
interaction because I can't get them to
actually interact. But these guys are
not serious. They're not a part of that
group. They want to be and they bark
really loud. Um and they try and pound
their chest, some of them. Um and put
out this front that they are, you know,
part of that group, but they're not. And
we're not going to be wasting time on
these silly antics anymore. Their
position here got absolutely buried.
Sam, anything you need to add?
Yeah, just keep praying for both Miles
and myself. That's it. Pray God will
preserve this young man. That God will
increase his platform. And I'm doing all
I can to get people. I always say he's
the man. The Lord preserve him, preserve
his channel. Pray for me, brethren, I
don't get a third strike. The Lord
preserve my YouTube channel. If the Lord
is pleased, allow it to be deleted, then
I'll start from scratch. Pray that we
walk worthy of the Lord. The Lord heal
me and forgive me of my vices. That I
practice what I preach. The Lord provide
for his ministry, provide for us, and we
finish the race and dwell with Jesus
forever because Jesus is Lord and he
lives. And we pray you Adventists come
to the true Christ.
Amen.
[Music]